ich begrüße Sie herzlich an diesem
Freitagmorgen und teile ihn mit dass
sich der Ältestenrat in seiner gestrigen
Sitzung darauf verständigt hat während
der Haushaltsberatungen ab Dienstag dem
22 März 2022 bis Freitag dem 25 März
2022 wie üblich keine Befragung der
Bundesregierung keine Fragestunde und
auch keine aktuellen Stunden
durchzuführen sind Sie damit
einverstanden das ist der offenkundig
der Fall dann verfahren wir so als
Präsenztage nach Paragraph 14 Abs 1 des
abgeordnetengesetzes werden die Tage von
Montag dem 21 märz bis Freitag dem 25
März 2022
festgelegt
wir haben außerdem jetzt eine Wahl
durchzuführen auf Vorschlag der Fraktion
der CDU CSU soll der Kollege Friedrich
Merz als Nachfolger für den Kollegen
Ralf Brinkhaus als stellvertretendes
Mitglied des Ausschusses nach Artikel 77
Absatz 2 des Grundgesetzes des
Vermittlungsausschusses gewählt werden
ich sehe kein Widerspruch dann ist der
Kollege Friedrich Merz als
stellvertretendes Mitglied des
Vermittlungsausschusses gewählt
auf Verlangen der Fraktion der AFD wird
heute als letzter Punkt der Tagesordnung
eine Aktuelle Stunde stattfinden mit dem
Thema Haltung der Bundesregierung zu den
Vorwürfen gegen Anne Spiegel im
Zusammenhang mit der Flutkatastrophe
so weit die Mitteilungen vor Eintritt in
die Tagesordnung ich rufe auf die
Tagesordnungspunkte
21a bis
21e sowie die Zusatzpunkte 15 17 und 18
Beratung mehrere Vorlagen zu
coronabedingten Regelungen zur dritten
Beratung des Gesetzentwurfs zur Änderung
des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes liegen ein
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
AFD sowie ein Entschließungsantrag der
Fraktion Die Linke vor über diesen
Gesetzentwurf werden wir später
namentlich abstimmen
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten beschlossen bevor ich die
Aussprache eröffne sei mir der Hinweis
gestattet sie dürfen auch heute mit der
Kollegin katrin Göring-Eckardt und mit
mir hier vorlieb nehmen und wir bleiben
danke schön
wir bleiben bei den Regelungen die wir
seit Mittwoch hier praktizieren
natürlich ist das waagerecht und
bemerkungsrecht gewährleistet aber es
gibt kein natürliches Recht auf
kurzinterventionen wenn eine Frage
abgewiesen wurde sondern wir fahren dann
in den Beratungen fort
ich eröffne die Aussprache das Wort hat
der Bundesminister Herr lauterbach
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Pandemie ist leider noch
nicht vorbei und wir brauchen weitere
Schutzmaßnahmen und um solche zu
beschließen sind wir heute
zusammengekommen wir haben viel
geschafft aber wir sind nicht an dem
Punkt wo schon an Frieden day kommen
könnte wir sind heute nicht
zusammengekommen über den Frieden day zu
sprechen und der Frieden der wäre auch
nicht das Ende der Schutzmaßnahmen der
Freedom Day wäre das Ende der Pandemie
und den Frieden der den besprechen wir
somit nicht heute den Frieden die haben
wir gestern besprochen denn unseren
Frieden die können wir erreichen wenn
wir diese Pandemie beenden indem wir die
allgemeine Impfpflicht beschließen das
ist der einzige sichere aus der Pandemie
heraus wir können die Pandemie nicht
beschließen indem wir einfach die
Schutzmaßnahmen einstellen wir brauchen
die schutzmaßen solange wir die hohe
Zahl von ungeimpften haben dann muss
immer wieder erinnert werden und wir
wären schon viel weiter als wir sind
wenn uns dies gelingen könnte
wenn wir
wenn wir uns heute die Fallzahlen
anschauen fast 300.000 Fälle werden wir
uns heute die Todeszahlen anschauen über
200 Menschen sind gestorben das kann uns
nicht zufriedenstellen das ist extrem
unbefriedigend dazu kommt die deutsche
Sonderrolle die über 60-Jährigen zu
einem hohen
Maß ungeimpft viel mehr als in unserer
Nachbarländern und wir haben darüber
hinaus eine relativ alte Bevölkerung
daher brauchen wir Schutzmaßnahmen
Schutzmaßnahmen die in anderen Ländern
in diesem Umfang nicht mehr notwendig
sind
ich finde es ich muss das einmal sagen
ich finde es traurig wenn wir über so
ein wichtiges Thema sprechen und wir
müssen uns all diese Zeit diese
niederträchtigen Unterstellungen und
Einwürfe anhören das ist einfach
schlicht eine Störung und ich finde ich
meine ich komme damit gut zu Recht ich
komme damit gut zurecht aber ich es
spricht hohen der Bedeutung der Fragen
die wir hier debattieren die
Ernsthaftigkeit wir können dir
unterschiedlicher Meinung sein und wir
werden auch streiten wir werden in der
Sache streiten wir werden in der Sache
schreiben aber die Ernsthaftigkeit
dieser Debatte wird von ihnen in Abrede
gestellt das können wir nicht hinnehmen
das ist eine Art das ist eine
unglaubliche
Verhöhnung der Opfer die wir hier und
ich möchte noch einmal ich möchte noch
etwas sagen wir sprechen heute über
einen schweren Kompromiss das ist aber
nicht der Kompromiss das ist nicht der
Kompromiss über den wir heute sprechen
zwischen Themen Freiheit und dem
Vorsicht sondern wir sprechen heute über
einen Kompromiss was können wir den
Menschen noch zumuten die sich all die
Zeit an die Regeln halten die unsere
Kinder was was können wir den Menschen
noch zumuten die die Regeln beachten und
was sind wir bereit denjenigen zuzumuten
die gar nichts bereit zur sind zu opfern
die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen
bitte nicht aussehen die außer stören
keinen einzigen konstruktiven Beitrag im
Verlauf der gesamten Pandemie bisher
haben lassen können ich sage
ich weiß dass ich als Epidemiologe
gewünscht hätte wir hätten mehr für
diejenigen tun können wir jetzt im
Risiko steht aber wir müssen die
rechtliche Lage beachten die rechtliche
Lage ist die wir können nicht weiter das
gesamte Land unter Schutz stellen um
eine kleine Gruppe von Impfung
unwilligen und denjenigen die nicht
bereit sind die Maßnahmen mitzutragen um
diese zu schützen die Balance wird
geändert das muss ich für
Herr Dr Lauterbach ich habe die Zeit
angehalten ich bitte Sie einen kleinen
Moment innezuhalten und ich sage es
heute morgen nur ein einziges Mal
es gilt die Allgemeinverfügung und das
heißt die Masken können zur Rede am Pult
bzw hier oben für die Präsidentinnen
abgesetzt werden auch für Zwischenrufe
gilt die maskenpflicht
es gab in den wenigen Minuten die wir
jetzt hier beisammen sind jetzt
mehrfachverstöße auf der rechten Seite
des Hauses gegen die Allgemeinverfügung
und
ich werde entsprechend unseren
Regelungen dies hier auch nachdrücklich
an ich bitte darum dass zu beachten
sollte irgendjemand aus welchen Gründen
auch immer hier nicht im Saal verweilen
können und die Maske weiter tragen
können dann muss er bitte die Debatte
anderweitig verfolgen
sie haben wieder das Wort Herr Minister
Lauterbach die Regelung die wir heute
vorstellen ist eine Regelung die
folgender Tatsache Rechnung stellt wir
haben durch die omikon Variante nicht
mehr die Situation dass das gesamte Land
gefährdet ist in dem Sinne dass wir eine
Überlastung dass wir eine Überlastung
der Kliniken dass wir eine Überlastung
der Kliniken flächendeckend zu
befürchten haben trotzdem würde es so
sein dass in vielen Stellen tatsächlich
genau diese Überlastung kommen wird und
daher haben wir die Regel angepasst dass
überall dort wo wir eine Überlastung der
Krankenhäuser und der
Gesundheitsversorgung erwarten müssen
dass dort die hotspot-regelung zählt und
wir dann auch weitergehende Maßnahmen
ergreifen können und wo das nicht der
Fall ist wenn es nicht gemacht darauf
haben wir uns angepasst hätten wir dies
nicht gemacht hätten wir keine Regel
mehr gehabt denn dann hätte es entweder
die Möglichkeit gegeben wir machen die
Regeln über überall Maßnahmen auch dort
wo es keine Überlastung gibt das wäre
rechtlich nicht gegangen oder wir hätten
ganz auf die Regeln verzichtet Frieden
die dann hätten wir gar nichts gehabt
somit ist die Begrenzung der Regeln auf
die Teile Deutschlands wo tatsächlich
die Überlastung zu befürchten ist das
ist der richtige Kompromiss und das ist
ein Kompromiss das ist nicht Freiheit
gegen Vorsicht sondern das trägt einfach
der Tatsache Rechnung dass wir so
überhaupt noch zielgerecht reagieren
können und da bitte ich um Ihr Vertrauen
wir werden das durchsetzen die Landtage
werden das auch umsetzen können und wo
ein ganzes Land betroffen ist das sind
Herr Buschmann und ich auch einer
Meinung das wurde immer falsch
dargestellt wo ein ganzes Land Hotspot
ist da kann das ganze Land dann auch als
Hotspot gelten das ist zum Beispiel
etwas was jetzt auch in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern er testet wird
somit wir brauchen Ihr Vertrauen wir
brauchen funktionierende Regeln ich
bitte Sie diesem Gesetz zuzustimmen es
wird uns für die nächsten Monate helfen
wenn die Lage sich verändert wenn wir
andere Varianten zu bekommen wenn die
Gesundheitsversorgung stärker gefährdet
ist wenn wir beispielsweise eine
gefährliche rohrmikonvariante bekommen
dann wirkt zunächst einmal dieses Gesetz
aber dann sind wir auch bereit jederzeit
das
Infektionsschutzgesetz erneut anzupassen
um dieser neuen Lage Rechnung zu tragen
[Applaus]
das Wort hat der Kollege Timo Sorge für
die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
das Gesetz was wir heute hier
abschließend debattieren hatte zwei
klare Aufgaben erste Aufgabe Lockerungen
verantwortungsbewusst für das Frühjahr
vorbereiten die zweite Aufgabe
Absicherung dafür herzustellen falls ich
die infektionslage
verbessert oder verschlechtert beides
leistet das Gesetz nicht viel mehr
erzeugt es einen Bürger und dieses
wirrwa das haben nicht nur
bierkritisiert sondern auch alle
Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidenten der Bundesländer und
ich finde das schon bemerkenswert Herr
Kollege Lauterbach wenn Sie sich hier
hinstellen und sagen in der Koalition
sei Einigkeit darüber erzeugt wurden was
Hotspots sind also ich habe jetzt ihren
Bundesjustizminister nicht klatschen
sehen weil der sieht das offensichtlich
ganz anders als sie was ein Hotspot sein
kann also insofern wenn sie es schon
nicht einig sind dann müssen Sie sich
nicht wundern wenn die Länder nicht
wissen wie sie das umsetzen sollen und
ich kann Ihnen ganz klar sagen wir haben
ja gestern die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz der Länder
gehabt es ist ein absolutes Novum in der
Geschichte das 16 Ministerpräsident und
Ministerpräsidenten dieser
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in
protokollerklärungen sagen dass das so
nicht geht dass das wirrware erzeugt
dass die Ampel auf Rot gelb-grün steht
und im Grunde das Chaos mit Ansage ist
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
ich könnte es mir ich könnte es mir sehr
sehr einfach machen ich müsste ja im
Grunde bloß diese Protokollerklärung
vorlegen deshalb habe ich sie mir hier
noch mal mitgebracht ich lese mal die
ersten beiden Punkte vor dieser
Protokollerklärung in Top 6 da sagen
zahlreiche Bundesländer
die Länder bedauern dass die geplanten
Änderungen des Infektionsschutzgesetzes
weitestgehend ohne Beteiligung der
Länder konzipiert worden sind obwohl die
Länder maßgeblich für den Vollzug
zuständig sind erster Punkt weiterer
Punkt die nunmehr durch den Bund
angestrebte Änderungen des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes bleibt hinter
diesem Schutzniveau zurück zudem ist die
vorgesehene Hotspot Regelung rechtlich
nicht sicher umsetzbar und praktisch
nicht durchsetzbar liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und da fragen Sie allen Ernstes
was wollen Sie mit diesem Gesetz
erreichen glauben Sie ernsthaft dass wir
mit diesem Gesetz Rechtssicherheit in
den Ländern erzeugen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
und das was sie hier gesagt haben Herr
Kollege Lauterbach ist ja dass sie
definieren wie dieser Instrumentenkasten
aussehen könnte und die Bundesländer
haben gesagt wir brauchen ein
Instrumentenkasten der eben genau auf
diese dynamische Lage reagieren lassen
kann sie haben definiert höhere
Pathogenität also wenn ein Virus mit
einer höheren Pathogenität sich zeigt
dass man dann schneller reagieren kann
plus was sie nicht definieren ist was
ist höhere Pathogenität sie sagen in
Bereichen wo besonders hohe
Neuinfektionen kommen kann reagiert
werden keiner weiß was meinen Sie mit
besonders hohen neuen Infektionen und
die drohende Klinik Überlastung im
Hinblick auf die Hotspots das ist genau
der Punkt der maßgebliche Punkt den Sie
innerhalb der Koalition nicht geklärt
haben Herr Kollege Lauterbach und da
sollten Sie dringend Nacharbeiten liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und deshalb
kann ich Ihnen nur sagen wir werden
dieses Gesetz ablehnen nicht nur weil es
handwerklich schlecht ist weil es in den
Einzelheiten nicht geklärt ist weil sein
einziger unscharfer Rechtsbegriff ist
wir werden es als Opposition ablehnen
aber auch Ihre Kolleginnen und Kollegen
in den Ländern Frau Giffey
beispielsweise hat gestern ja schon
angekündigt noch vor Verabschiedung des
Gesetzes dass das nachgebessert werden
muss also insofern gehe ich davon aus
dass wir uns sehr zeitnah hier wieder
sehen werden vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
hat nun die Kollegin Dr Kirsten Kappert
gonter das Wort
[Applaus]
liebe Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen zunächst wünsche ich
unserem Kollegen Janosch Damen schnelle
Genesung eigentlich hätte er hier
heute reden sollen doch auf ihn hat das
Corona-Virus erwischt dass er dafür
Sport und Häme hier sofort und auch im
Netz abbekommt das liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist unerträglich
sie hat gerade zu reflexhaft ja was sie
hier machen lieber Janosch unsere volle
Solidarität
es ist unerträglich ja Menschen sind
krank und er ist einer von etwa 300.000
Menschen die sich derzeit täglich neu
infizieren und wir wünschen allen von
ihnen ein milden Verlauf
doch leider doch leider liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wissen wir dass
es jeden Tag auch Menschen schwer trifft
das über 200 Menschen täglich sterben
und longkowit jeden und jede treffen
kann auch Kinder wir dürfen longkowit
nicht unterschätzen
und bei der Frage ob unser
Gesundheitssystem überlastet ist sollten
wir nicht nur auf die Intensivstationen
gucken die peripheren Stationen der
Krankenhäuser sind zurzeit stark unter
Druck alle Kolleginnen und Kollegen dort
ärztlich aus der Pflege alle Arbeiten am
Limit und überall sind die Menschen in
unserem Land unter Druck auch psychisch
und der Ton verschärft sich nicht nur
hier auch sonst aber wir können diese
Pandemie nur gemeinsam überwinden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und auch innerhalb einer
Koalition ist es in unserer Demokratie
notwendig Kompromisse zu finden das ist
das Wesen der Demokratie aus meiner
Sicht als Ärztin als
Gesundheitspolitikerin aus euch meiner
Fraktion und im übrigen auch der
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung braucht es für
einen guten Infektionsschutz vermutlich
mehr als das was heute in diesem Gesetz
vorliegt
wir wissen dass ffp2-masken einen guten
Schutz vor Ansteckung bieten und es wäre
gut weiterhin präventiv zu agieren und
die maskenpflicht flächendeckend
beizubehalten
und es ist kein Geheimnis dass wir auch
innerhalb der Koalition unterschiedliche
Positionen dazu hatten welche Maßnahmen
jetzt bundesweit weiterhin nötig sind
aber
kein Gesetz
wäre sehr viel schlechter gewesen als
dieses Gesetz was ja weiterhin
Schutzmaßnahmen beinhaltet und darum
werden wir als Bündnis 90 die Grünen
auch zustimmen auch wenn wir uns
deutlich mehr gewünscht hätten weil das
ist das was innerhalb der Ampel
vereinbar war und er Worst Case wäre
gewesen alle Schutzmaßnahmen auslaufen
zu lassen hier also mit diesem Gesetz
schützen wir natürlich mehr als ohne
Gesetz hier ist der Spatz in der Hand
natürlich deutlich mehr Schutz als die
Taube auf dem Dach
ich hoffe sehr dass die maskenpflicht
aber auch die maskenkür weiter genutzt
wird und zwar nicht nur für sich selbst
sondern auch für andere besonders
verletzliche Personen wer diese schützen
möchte trägt in diesem Frühjahr weiter
Masken beispielsweise im Supermarkt denn
dort kaufen Menschen ein mit kleinen
Kindern Menschen die sich nicht impfen
lassen konnten bisher und auch diese
sind auf unsere Solidarität angewiesen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist so
auf die Länder kommt jetzt eine große
Verantwortung zu sie können die
Übergangsfrist bis zum zweiten April
verlängern sie können Schutzmaßnahmen
fortführen und von der hotspot-regelung
Gebrauch machen viele Länder wie Bremen
Berlin Baden-Württemberg gehen schon in
diese Richtung das ist vermutlich sehr
klug und klar bleibt wenn die neuen
Maßnahmen nicht ausreichen werden müssen
wir nachsteuern denn diese Pandemie ist
noch nicht vorbei und wir werden sie nur
gemeinsam überwinden dankeschön
das Wort hat die Abgeordnete dr
Christine Baum für die afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
diese Entwurf auf den so viele Menschen
sehensüchtig warten weil sie endlich
wieder normal wieder frei leben wollen
ist nichts weiter als eine
Beruhigungspille denn die wenigen
Erleichterungen können jederzeit
aufgehoben werden ganz nach Lust und
Laune da es keine eindeutigen Parameter
für die Hotspots gibt die
corona-maßnahmen gehören schon deshalb
komplett vom Tisch weil das darf
erhobene Kriterium zu keinem Zeitpunkt
erfüllt war zu keinem Zeitpunkt gab es
eine Überlastung der Krankenhäuser oder
der Intensivstationen
evident basierte Studien zur Wirksamkeit
der corona-maßnahmen gibt es nicht deren
Schädlichkeit ist jedoch hinlänglich
bewiesen insbesondere bei Kindern und
Jugendlichen haben sie zu massiven
körperlichen und psychischen Schäden
geführt
Ängstlichkeit Depressionen es und sprach
Sprachstörungen bis hin zu generellen
Entwicklungsstörungen all das ist jedoch
nur die Spitze des Eisberges das Tragen
von Masken führt zu einem Anstieg von
Blutdruck und Herzfrequenz Kopfschmerzen
Schwindel Konzentrationsschwäche und
Hautirritationen wie in einer Metastudie
zum maskeninduzierten
erschöpfungssymptomen beschrieben wurde
ich zitiere aus einer Stellungnahme bei
einer öffentlichen Sitzung der
kinderschutzkommission des Deutschen
Bundestages am 9 September 2020 von
Professor Dr Michael klund Zitat alle
Entscheidungen und Maßnahmen der Politik
seit März April 2020 wurden
völkerrechtsverstoßend und
grundgesetzwidrig ohne vorrangige
Berücksichtigung des Kindeswohls
vorgenommen der Kindeswohl Vorrang ist
nicht nur ignoriert worden sondern aus
dem Kinderschutz wurde plötzlich der
Schutz vor Kindern sie wurden als Viren
Verbreiter wie Objekte behandelt diese
instrumentelle Behandlung von Kindern
betrachte ich als eine Form von
Kindeswohlgefährdung Zitat ändert
viel recht Professor klund damit hatte
beweist ein
corona-szenarienpapier des
Bundesministeriums
2020 darin können Sie auf Seite 13 lesen
um die gewünschte Schockwirkung zu
erzielen müssen die konkreten
Auswirkungen einer Durchseuchung auf die
menschliche Gesellschaft verdeutlicht
werden und unter Punkt 2 steht dass man
Kindern die Schuld dafür geben solle
dass sie ihre Eltern anstecken die dann
qualvoll zu Hause sterben das sei der
schrecklichste was ein Kind je erleben
könnte
dieses unmenschliche leid das sind
Kinder damit zugefügt würde wird für
immer mit ihren Namen verbunden sein
doch nicht nur die Kinder sind
geschädigt sondern die ganze
Gesellschaft als soziale Wesen sind wir
auf Kontakte Umarmungen und Nähe
angewiesen sie haben diese menschlichen
Urbedürfnisse verboten und mit welchem
Ergebnis
denzidenzen sind so hoch wie nie allein
das Zeug von der völligen Unwirksamkeit
aller Maßnahmen
das einzige was sie damit erreicht haben
ist die Schwächung der eigenen
Immunabwehr wir brauchen für ein
funktionierendes Immunsystem den Kontakt
mit Viren wir brauchen die Bewegung an
der frischen Luft wir brauchen
Sauerstoff zum Atmen und wir brauchen
liebevolle Umarmungen geben Sie unserem
Volk endlich ein menschenwürdiges Leben
und Lebensfreude zurück das ist die
beste Medizin vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die FDP-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
Lukas Köhler das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen lieber
Herr Sorge ich habe mich überrascht dass
sie so sehr auf die klare und eindeutige
Einhaltung das blinde Folgen quasi der
MPK Wochen würden ich kann mich daran
erinnern dass auch dieses Mal einstimmig
alle Ministerpräsidenten für eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht gestimmt haben
und ich werde würde mich wundern ob die
CDU nach den Vorträgen von gestern die
CSU dem auch so folgen würde das wäre
doch eine ganz andere
debattenlage her sorge also ich wäre
vorsichtig mit dem Forderungen die man
aufregt ich glaube aber und ich will
ihnen das gar nicht vorwerfen weil das
zeigt ja eine Sache wir sind lernfähig
wir entwickeln uns weiter wir entwickeln
unser Wissen weiter und ich glaube das
ist auch das was man in dieser Pandemie
dass wir in der Diskussion die wir hier
führen sehen und das ist auch das was
wir in den richtigen und notwendigen
Maßnahmen sehen die wir zum Schutz
sehen müssen denn meine Damen und Herren
die nicht die Freiheit von
Einschränkungen ist begründungsbedürftig
die Einschränkung der Freiheit ist
begründungsbedürftig und das müssen wir
bei jeder bei jeder einzelnen Maßnahme
die wir treffen immer wieder vor Augen
haben wir müssen wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass wir Politik so ausgestalten dass
nur das an den wenigen
freiheitseinschränkungen möglich ist das
notwendig ist und das ist das was wir
mit diesem Gesetzesentwurf das ist das
was wir in diesem Vorschlag tun wir
schützen auf der einen Seite sorgen aber
dafür dass wir so weit wie es irgendwie
geht zurück zu Normalität kommen
die Herausforderung vor der wir stehen
ist natürlich dass sich
pandemiegeschehen dass sich aber auch
wissen entwickelt und so war es ja ganz
klar dass vor dem Schleier der
Unwissenheit am Anfang der Pandemie
Entscheidung getroffen wurden bei denen
wir heute sagen sie waren damals falsch
oder unnötig aber zu dem Zeitpunkt wo
sie getroffen wurden hätten wir sie
nicht anders treffen können und deswegen
haben wir als Freie Demokraten sie auch
damals schon unterstützt in einer ganz
anderen Koalition und auch Konstellation
wir haben aber gesehen dass sich diese
Pandemie verändert wir haben gesehen
dass wir immense Infektionszahlen haben
dass wir eine sehr hohe Inzidenz haben
aber dass die Inzidenz heute nicht mehr
der ausschlaggebende Faktor ist einzig
und allein die Überlastung der
Krankenhäuser ist es
was wir politisch betrachten müssen was
jetzt in Zukunft die Landtage beachten
müssen und nicht die Frage inwiefern es
funktionieren kann dass wir immer
weitere Inzidenzen in immer
unterschiedlicheren Konstellationen
deswegen meine Damen und Herren
müssen wir auch weiterhin Freiheit und
Verantwortung koppeln aber es gibt ja
auch diejenigen die sagen
quasi wie Montesquieu wenn es nicht
nötig ist ein Gesetz zu machen ist es
nötig kein Gesetz zu machen das wäre
aber an dieser Stelle auch der falsche
Weg gewesen gar keine Maßnahmen gar
keine Schutzkonzepte keine Möglichkeit
für die Länder es hinzubekommen bei
einem hotspot-regelung zu treffen das
wäre auch der falsche Weg denn das wäre
Kollege Köhler gestatten Sie eine Frage
oder be des Kollegen Müller es würde mir
manche Street zu Ende bringen und das
ging leider nicht nein danke
diese Idee
dieses Gesetz
so zur auszugestalten dass wir auf der
einen Seite Schutz bei Hotspots haben
und auf der anderen Seite
dafür sorgen dass die Menschen in den
Alltag zurückfinden dass die Menschen
ihre Verantwortung umsetzen und ihre
Verantwortung gerecht werden können das
ist es was wir politisch einfordern
müssen denn meine Damen und Herren die
Menschen in Deutschland sind ja keine
kleinen Kinder wir verbieten niemanden
Masken zu tragen wir ermöglichen den
Menschen ihre eigene Verantwortung
selbst in die Hand zu nehmen und das ist
urkern auch einer liberalen Idee und das
ist es doch meine Damen und Herren was
wir in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
im nächsten halben Jahr sehen werden das
heißt aber nicht dass wir nicht vor
neuen
Varianten vor neuen Entwicklungen in der
Pandemie geschützt werden das heißt auch
nicht dass wir nicht lernfähig werden
denn natürlich können wir weiterhin
lernen natürlich werden wir auch zum
Herbst wenn es notwendig ist mehr
beschießen wir können auch über den
Sommer mehr beschließen denn Politik ist
handlungsfähig Politik beschließt nicht
etwas das in Steinen gemeißelt ist
sondern Politik reagiert und kluge
Pandemie Politik reagiert klug und das
ist es was wir mit diesem Gesetzentwurf
machen meine Damen und Herren
die sehen auch die Impfpflicht anders
meine Damen und Herren
der Zeitpunkt jetzt ist völlig richtig
in diese Richtung weiterzugehen wir
sehen im europäischen Vergleich dass wir
mit diesem Gesetz zumindest nicht mehr
alleine da stehen wir sehen dass wir mit
diesen Änderungen einen gemeinsamen Weg
aus der Pandemie gehen können
und natürlich ist es wichtig dass die
Menschen weiterhin
verantwortungsbewusst mit der Pandemie
natürlich ist es wichtig dass die
Menschen sich impfen lassen natürlich
wissen wir dass auch weitere
Entwicklungen in der Pandemie nach dem
19 nicht zu Ende sind und wir wissen
trotzdem dass es viele Menschen in und
die allermeisten Menschen in Deutschland
gibt die verantwortungsbewusst mit ihrer
Freiheit umgehen und das ist es was wir
mit diesem Gesetz schaffen deswegen
vielen Dank für die Debatte vielen Dank
für dieses Gesetz und auf ein gutes
weiteres
[Applaus]
das Wort hat die Kollegin Susanne
ferschel für die Fraktion DIE LINKE
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
Minister die Bundesregierung möchte
gerne die fortschrittskoalition sein
aber was bitte ist daran fortschrittlich
dauernd Gesetze im Schweinsgalopp durch
das Parlament zu treiben die dann auch
noch handwerklich und inhaltlich
schlecht sind
dieses atomverfahren beim
Infektionsschutz das haben wir jetzt
seit zwei Jahren und die Ampel die Top
tatsächlich auch noch die groko nur den
pflegebonus den haben sie nicht
innerhalb einer Woche hinbekommen an dem
doktance
ja
Omicron verursacht zum Glück weniger
schwere Verläufe und ja die
Ausgangssituation ist eine andere als
vor zwei Jahren aber bei einem
Höchststand an Infektionen und bei
täglichen longkowit und Todesfällen
lockert man doch nicht von 100 auf
nahezu Null
zugunsten der Freedom day-partei genannt
FDP geben Bundesregierung und
Gesundheitsminister der ansonsten der
ewige Mahner in der Pandemie gewesen ist
hier eine politische bankroterklärung ab
ihre regionale hotspot-regelung die
schafft einen Flicken
Teppichen damit die Bundesländer im
Regen stehen und sie fördern auch noch
den föderalen überbietungs- und
Unterbietungswettbewerb das ist wirklich
absurd meine Damen und Herren
und apropos absurd sie schaffen die
maskenpflicht als Basisschutz ab obwohl
Masken nachweislich für Infektionen
schützen diskutieren aber gleichzeitig
über die Einführung einer allgemeinen
Impfpflicht diese Impfpflicht ist aber
wesentlich freiheitseinschränkender als
sich die Pflicht sich für eine halbe
Stunde im Bus oder im Bahn oder im
Supermarkt eine Maske um Mund und Nase
zu binden
und dann Entschuldigung dieses blöde
Argument von der FDP ja man dürfe ja
weiterhin die Maske tragen es geht aber
nicht nur um Eigenschutz sondern es geht
um fremdschutz und das offenbar zu
deutlich ihr crudesverständnis von
Freiheit nämlich Freiheit von
Solidarität und Rücksicht
sie wollen arabiengruppen die sie
angeblich schützen wollen die leben
nämlich nicht nur im Heim die leben
mitten in unserer Gesellschaft pflegende
Angehörige Eltern von Kindern mit
Vorerkrankungen Vorerkrankungen die
kommen offensichtlich in ihren
Paralleluniversum gar nicht vor das ist
beschämend
und um es auf allen Ebenen absurd zu
machen wird der Infektionsschutz am
Arbeitsplatz auch noch untergefahren
wenn Tests Masken und Homeoffice der
Beliebigkeit der Arbeitgeber unterliegen
ist die Gesundheit der Beschäftigten
gefährdet und es ist völlig inakzeptabel
nach zwei Jahren Pandemie ist doch
wirklich nicht zu viel verlangt einen
Plan vorzulegen der uns durch diese und
künftige Pandemien bringt die Linke hat
hierzu einen Antrag eingebracht und wir
brauchen klare wenn dann Regelungen die
bei vergleichbaren Infektionsgeschehen
auch vergleichbare Maßnahmen die wir
leisten kostenfreie Tests auch PCR-Tests
und eine Ausweitung der Impfkampagne der
ist nach wie vor Luft nach oben und
und einen Rechtsanspruch auf
Infektionsschutz am Arbeitsplatz und auf
Homeoffice
meine Damen und Herren die große
Mehrheit in diesem Land hält sich jetzt
seit zwei Jahren besonnen und
solidarisch an die Regeln aber durch
Intransparenz Hauruckverfahren falsche
Versprechungen zum Beispiel auf ein Ende
der Pandemie geht mit jeder neuen Welle
mehr Vertrauen in Politik und Staat
verloren ihr Gesetz trägt weiter dazu
bei und deswegen denen wir es rundherum
ab vielen Dank
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
Dirk Wiese das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Zahlen der
letzten Tage die uns immer wieder
erreichen machen glaube ich eins
deutlich dass wir weiter sehr
verantwortungsvoll mit dieser aktuellen
Situation und dem Pandemie Geschehen
umgehen müssen und das vollkommen
richtig auch aufgrund der aktuellen Lage
was Karl Lauterbach gerade auch
ausgeführt hat wir werden mit diesem
Gesetz sicherlich keinen Freedom Day in
diesem Land haben und das ist auch nicht
etwas was die Ampel letztendlich mit
diesem Gesetz verfolgt sondern ist ein
weiterer verantwortungsvoller Umgang mit
der aktuellen Situation denn ich will
das noch mal deutlich machen die
Regelung in 28a und 28b das gelten
Infektionsschutzgesetzes die würden wenn
wir keine fortgesetzte Regelung finden
würden die wir heute auf den Weg bringen
auslaufen und das würde bedeuten wenn
wir nichts tun würde es künftig gar
keine Maßnahmen wie test- oder
maskenpflicht mehr geben können und das
vor dem Hintergrund der aktuellen Zahl
kurz um
Rechtsgrundlagen für die Länder würden
wenn wir heute nicht dieses Gesetz auf
den Weg bringen ersatzlos wegfallen und
das kann aus unserer Sicht nicht sein
und darum ist es richtig diesen
vertretbaren Kompromiss heute auch auf
den Weg zu bringen
und das will ich sagen es ist richtig
diesen praktikablen Kompromiss den wir
als Ampelkoalition verhandelt haben auf
den Weg zu bringen die Situation ist
anders als
infektionsschutzgesetzänderungen die wir
in den vergangenen Jahren gehabt haben
da wir eine hohe Zahl an Impfungen
letztendlich auch haben die nachweislich
vor einem schweren Verlauf auch schützen
oder darum will ich Dank sagen an
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach und
als auch ein Bundesjustizminister
Buschmann die gemeinsam mit uns als
Koalition diesen Kompromiss auf den Weg
gebracht haben und Herr Sorge sie
wussten dass vielleicht nicht beide
haben dem zugestimmt nur man darf auf
der Regierungsbank nicht klatschen darum
waren sie vielleicht in den letzten
Jahren irritiert dass wir in Spanien
Ihnen die Applaus gegeben hat aber das
ist eigentlich Konsens im Bundestag aber
vielleicht wissen sie das an der Stelle
noch nicht ich glaube der Kompromiss ist
vertretbar ergibt eine Perspektive auch
im Rahmen einer verantwortungsvollen
öffnungsperspektive Schritte die auch
vereinbart worden sind aber wir müssen
uns glaube ich sehr deutlich bewusst
machen gerade für die Situation des
kommenden Herbst und Winters müssen
diese vorsorgen wir wollen dass diese
Pandemie beherrschbar wird und vor dem
Hintergrund ist es wichtig Vorsorge zu
treffen letztendlich mit einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht die wir Anfang
April hier in zweiter dritter Lesung auf
den Weg bringen wollen es ist ein
angewiesen wir starten Sie eine Frage
oder Bemerkung des Kollegen Sorge
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Wiese das sind
die Zwischenfrage zulassen dass sie mich
ja direkt angesprochen haben will ich
sie ganz kurz Fragen finden Sie das
parlamentarische Verfahren normal und
ein Zeichen guter Zusammenarbeit wenn
noch vor der Verabschiedung des Gesetzes
16 Ministerpräsidentin und
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder sagen das
Gesetz ist schlecht das geht so nicht
sie wissen es nicht wie es jetzt
umsetzen soll und finden Sie es normal
dass noch vor der ersten Lesung dieses
Gesetzes die Anhörung stattfinden muss
weil es zeitlich nicht anders ging
obwohl man seit Monaten wusste dass hier
neue Regelungen auf den Weg gebracht
werden müssen
sehr geehrter Kollege Sorge haben sie
erstmal vielen Dank für die
Zwischenfrage Entschuldigung
nicht so
und die letzten Halbzeit ist es durch
das Mikro ein bisschen untergegangen und
das Verbände sagen dass das völlig
atypisch sei das heißt Sie bekommen den
Gesetzentwurf um 0 Uhr 18 einem Sonntag
zugesandt und sollen bis 10 Uhr am
Montag morgen dazu Stellungen finden sie
das alles normal im parlamentarischen
Verfahren vielen Dank
sehr geehrter Kollege Sorge haben sie
vielen Dank für die Zwischenfrage weil
mir das die Möglichkeit gibt und ich
sehe den früheren Gesundheitsminister
Jens Spanier auch hier heute bei der
Debatte sitzen ich habe seit Mai 2020
einige Änderungen des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes mitverhandeln
dürfen auch in der großen Koalition und
ich kann Ihnen sagen dass dieses
Verfahren sicherlich zeitlich sehr
anspruchsvoll gewesen ist dass es sich
aber wohltuend abhebt von dem was wir
unter der Leitung von hell gebrauen im
Kanzleramt in Teilen erlebt haben wir
haben teilweise sehr hektische
Verhandlungen geführt worden teilweise
sind aus dem Kanzleramt damals Sachen an
die Bildzeitung durchgestochen worden
und darum kann ich nur sagen es hebt
sich sehr wohltuend ab wie die
Bundesregierung diese Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes in der
Ampelkoalition angeht ansonsten würde
ich mich freuen wenn sie stehen bleiben
solange ich Ihre Frage auch beantwortet
ich glaube das gebietet auch der Respekt
untereinander bei Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
es ist letztendlich ein Kompromiss den
wir auf den Weg bringen der die Menschen
die vulnerablen Gruppen ganz besonders
schützen möchte und in dem Blick nimmt
er ist aber auch ein Kompromiss der auch
die Verhältnismäßigkeit war und darum
ist es richtig wohl eine rabble Gruppen
besonders zu schützen es ist auch
richtig die maskenpflicht gerade im ÖPNV
letztendlich auch weiter zu behalten und
es ist auch richtig dass wir den Ländern
die Möglichkeit geben bei Vorliegen
einer konkreten Gefahr einer sich
dynamisch ausbreitenden infektionslage
weitergehende Schutzmaßnahmen im Rahmen
einer hotspot-regelung auf den Weg zu
bringen und das heißt die Länder können
letztendlich für Kreise für kreisfreie
Städte aber auch für das gesamte
Bundesland diese Hotspot Regelungen auf
den Weg bringen das halte ich für
richtig und ich sage es auch sehr
deutlich ich finde es richtig dass die
Länder den Weg über die Landtage gehen
müssen die Kollegin und Kollegen in den
Landtagen können das verantwortlich
machen die werden das gut machen und das
ist die demokratische Rückkopplung die
wir an der Stelle auch brauchen
jetzt habe ich allerdings auch den ein
oder anderen Hinweis ja gerade auch
vernommen her Sorge auch von ihrer Rede
bezüglich der Ministerpräsidenten ich
will aber mal einen Blick in die
christdemokratische Praxis in den
Bundesländern letztendlich werfen wo
waren denn die Verschärfungen aufgrund
einer steigenden Infektionsgeschehen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen vom
Ministerpräsident wüst nach dem Kölner
Karneval wo hat die Landesregierung denn
da die entsprechende Notwendigkeiten
gesehen voranzugehen und wenn ich mir
anschaue was derzeit in der
corona-schutzverordnung des Landes
Nordrhein-Westfalen geregelt ist und was
das Land mit den öffnungsschritten
voranbringen will in Nordrhein-Westfalen
dann ist das übrigens deckungsgleich mit
dem was wir in dem zukünftigen
Infektionsschutzgesetz den Ländern zur
Verfügung stellen von daher scheinen
ihre Ministerpräsidenten an dem Punkt
doch sehr zufrieden zu sein und von
daher verstehe ich den ein oder anderen
Punkt der an der Stelle nicht will aber
auch mal deutlich machen
und da will ich mal einen Blick nach
Bayern werfen und entschuldigen Sie Herr
Dobrindt das was ich jetzt ausführe ist
die Gemütslage des bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten von gestern Abend
das kann durchaus sein dass er seine
Meinung bis heute morgen geändert hat
aber
und das ist ein entscheidender Punkt
Bayern schafft ab kommenden Montag die
maskenpflicht für Grundschüler in den
Schulen ab die Übergangsregelung die wir
den Bundesländern gewähren würde die
Möglichkeit geben dies noch bis zum
zweiten vierten auch zu machen dann kann
es letztendlich ja nicht so sein dass
wie Markus Söder das schildert hier
Maßnahmen die er zur Verfügung hätte für
ihn nicht ausreichend sind das heißt er
macht gar nicht gebraucht von
Übergangsregelungen die wir Ihnen im
Infektionsschutzgesetz zur Verfügung
stellen und das muss ich schon sagen das
was Düsseldorf und München da
letztendlich vor Ort machen das ist in
einer gewissen Weise unglaubwürdig und
widerspricht dem was sie heute an dem
Gesetz kritisiert vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
für die cdu/csu-fraktion hat nun die
Kollegin Silvia Breer das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen heute beraten
wir auch den Antrag der cdu/csu-fraktion
zur Verlängerung der Corona bedingten
elterngeldregelungen und ich muss schon
sagen wir haben uns doch sehr gewundert
als im Rahmen ihres Entwurfs zum sodek
bei all den Verlängerungen der
corona-bedingten Sonderregeln niemand
aus ihrer Koalition und auch nicht die
zuständige
Bundesfamilienministerin Spiegel an die
Verlängerung der corona-bedingten
elterngeldregeln gedacht hat
aber wir helfen ja gerne als Opposition
und deswegen freue ich mich dass Sie
unseren Änderungsantrag vollständig
übernommen haben aber eins
lernt man eigentlich schon in der Schule
beim Abschreiben das selbstständige
Denken nicht einstellen denn auch die
besseren Schüler machen mal einen Fehler
wie sie haben nämlich auch den
redaktionellen Fehler der uns
unterlaufen ist in unserem
Änderungsantrag in der Begründung eins
zu eins übernommen
vielleicht besteht ja noch die
Möglichkeit der Korrektur schauen Sie
mal nach wir haben verwiesen auf Satz 3
in § 2b Absatz 1 beg es müsste Satz 4
sein und der Fehler ist ihnen
unterlaufen vielleicht korrigieren Sie
das aber
aber es geht uns um die Sache es geht
uns um die vielen Eltern die in den
nächsten Tagen ein Kind erwarten die in
den vergangenen Tagen und Wochen Eltern
geworden sind es geht um die Eltern die
in den vergangenen drei Monaten
pandemiebedingt in Kurzarbeit waren oder
Arbeitslosengeld bezogen haben deren
Kinder krank waren oder die die Kinder
zu Hause betreuen mussten weil die
Einrichtungen kita-schule
pandemiebedingt geschlossen waren diese
Eltern müssen nun zukünftig nicht mehr
fürchten weniger Elterngeld zu bekommen
denn die Monate in denen sie
Kurzarbeitergeld Arbeitslosengeld
Kinderkrankengeld oder andere
pandemiebedingte Sonderregelung erhalten
haben die können außer ausgeklammert
werden es geht aber auch um die Eltern
die aufgrund der Pandemie den
partnerschaftsbonus nicht bekommen
können weil einfach die Zeiten so waren
wie sie sind auch diese Eltern müssen
nun nicht mehr fürchten dass sie kein
Elterngeld bekommen oder noch viel
schlimmer es zurückzahlen müssen für all
diese jungen Eltern haben wir uns als
oppos schon stark gemacht und letztlich
auch die Koalition überzeugt die
pandemiebedingten Sonderregeln werden im
bundeseltern Geld und im
elternzeitgesetz nicht nur verlängert
sondern rückwirkend ab Ende Dezember 22
gelten und das ist eine gute Nachricht
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
hat nun der Kollege Andreas audritsch
das Wort
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
ich will mit großer Ehrlichkeit diese
Rede beginnen die Debatte heute die
Abstimmungen die anstehen nachher die
fallen mir persönlich äußerst schwer
weil ich bezweifle dass das vorliegende
Infektionsschutzgesetz letztlich der
Lage die wir haben angemessen ist wir
hätten uns auch andere auch
weitergehende Regelungen vorstellen
können und das ist auch kein Geheimnis
in diesem Haus bei steigenden
Infektionszahlen immer mehr
Krankenhauseinweisungen auch vielen
Toten jeden Tag die basisschutzmaßnahmen
so weit nach unten zu fahren so rigoros
nach unten zu fahren das ist nicht die
vorsorgende Politik die wir gerne auch
hier beschlossen hätten zumindest die
maskenpflicht
zumindest die maskenpflicht in
Innenräumen hätte bestehen bleiben
müssen und lieber Kollege Köhler liebe
FDP wenn Menschen mit Vorerkrankungen
sich zu Hause einschließen müssen weil
unsere Gesellschaft weil wir
zurücksichtslos dafür sind Masken in
öffentlichen Räumen zu tragen dann ist
das nicht mein Verständnis von Freiheit
heute hier Frühstück zuzustimmen fällt
mir schwer und dennoch werbe ich dafür
weil die Alternative keine Regelungen zu
haben keine Alternative ist und weil wir
viele andere Regelungen heute hier haben
die wir mit beschließen es geht um die
Eltern das wurde gerade gesagt das ist
richtig es geht aber auch um die vielen
sozialen Einrichtungen die wir in
Deutschland haben und die wir
selbstverständlich sichern müssen und
vor dem bankrotschiff zu schützen müssen
das sozialdienstleister einsatzgesetz
ist ein Schutzschirm den ganz viele
brauchen und ganz viele sind so froh
darüber dass wir es schaffen dass heute
hier zu verabschieden und schon allein
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir weiter
gesetzliche Regelungen haben
wir brauchen wir brauchen so dringend
dringend die Wohlfahrtsverbände die
müttergenesungswerke wir brauchen die
freien Kita-Träger wir brauchen die
Anbieter von Sprachkursen
selbstverständlich wir brauchen
Einrichtungen für Menschen mit
Behinderungen all das ist das was wir in
der Gesellschaft gerade in einer solchen
Pandemie brauchen und die Menschen die
dort arbeiten die haben über ihrer
Belastungsgrenze in den letzten Monaten
gearbeitet die haben unterstützt die
haben die haben geholfen die haben
unterrichtet so wie es eben gerade noch
ging und diese Menschen die verdienen
Respekt die verdienen Anerkennung die
verdienen aber viel mehr die verdienen
dass wir hier heute sicherstellen dass
sie gut finanziert und sicher
aufgestellt auch in dieser
Krisensituation ihre Arbeit machen
können
[Applaus]
und wo
und wo könnte das plastischer werden als
wenn wir uns die Kinder und jugendreha
anschauen in dieser Pandemie und das
wissen wir alle haben Kinder und
Jugendliche so unglaublich auch immer
wieder ertragen müssen sie haben immer
wieder gelitten und wenn wir diesen
Kindern und Jugendlichen eine Zukunft
geben wollen dann müssen wir die soziale
Infrastruktur sichern die diesen Kindern
und Jugendlichen hilft die dort hingeht
wo die Probleme sind und die Menschen
dann auch eine Perspektive aus dieser
schwierigen Lage heraus entwickeln kann
bei all diesen
bei all diesen Institutionen bei all
diesen Institutionen herrscht weiter
Ausnahmezustand und dann kann man so oft
wie man will hier in diesem Parlament
auch den Normalzustand herbeirreden es
wird dadurch nicht besser dort herrscht
Ausnahmezustand und so viele haben mit
mir jetzt in den Wochen davor gesprochen
und darum gebeten dass wir diese Gesetze
verlängern genau das tun wir ich habe
große Sorgen dass das was wir dass das
was wir heute beschließen nicht
ausreicht und dennoch ist es richtig
genau das zu tun was wir heute tun
dankeschön
Frau Abgeordnete beide wir führen hier
exakt ein redezeitprotokoll und managen
auch mit den Fraktionen bei Redezeit
Überziehung das Redezeiten entsprechend
abgezogen werden so wie wir das auch
seit Mittwochmittag und im Übrigen nicht
nur in dieser Woche praktizieren das
Präsidium braucht dazu jetzt keine
Unterstützung aus dem Plenum
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Stefan
Brandner für die afd-fra
[Applaus]
ja guten Morgen frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren das
Infektionsschutzgesetz steht mal wieder
auf der Tagesordnung ein schwieriges
Thema wenn man den Zensoren von Youtube
und Co entgehen möchte ich versuche es
trotzdem mal es ist das ein paar Stunden
her dass Herr Lauterbach einer der
größten impflamisten in diesem Lande
hier von hier vorne ein Bares
Horrorszenario an die Wand gemalt hat
zwar im Rahmen der Impfzwang Debatte am
gestrigen Tag ich habe die Debatte ja
verfolgt der Lauterbach sie haben eine
knappe Minute gebraucht und in dieser
knappen Minute in am Anfang ihrer Rede
waren halbes dutzendantische
Schreckenszenarien die alle über uns
hereinbrechen werden ich sage im Voraus
kein einziges dieser Schreckenszenarien
wird eintreffen mir Lauterbach sie sind
ein Lügner von hier vorne gewesen immer
schon und sie werden es auch bleiben und
ich denke dran an ihre Aussage Herbst
2021 mit Krokodilstränen haben die
prognostiziert Wissen März 2022 sein in
Deutschland alle geimpft genesen oder
leider gestorben das lebende Beispiel
her klabauterbach steht hier vor Ihnen
weder geimpft noch genesen und auch noch
nicht gestorben das mag jetzt daran
liegen dass noch nicht Ende März ist sie
haben sich ja etwas den März angeht
nicht festgelegt das mag auch vielleicht
daran liegen dass die großen Unsinn
erzählt haben ich vermute mal letzteres
und erwarte von Ihnen der Lauterbach
dass sie sich bei den vielen Millionen
Menschen die sie mit dieser Aussage in
Angst und Panik versetzt haben zumindest
entschuldigen es sind nicht Millionen
Menschen gestorben die nicht geimpft
sind und da macht das die Sache auch
nicht besser dass der Herr Spahn den
habe ich irgendwo gesehen ihn dabei
sekundiert hat der Herr Spahn übrigens
der offenbar mit Gesundheitspolitik
nichts mehr am Hut hat der macht jetzt
in Wirtschaft und Energie wahrscheinlich
gibt es da die besseren lobbyverträge
ersparen also ein Verlust für die
Gesundheit
für die Gesundheitspolitik ist das nicht
wenn ich mit diesem impflamismus ja
Lauterbach von hier vorne anschaue dann
bin ich der Überzeugung gekommen wir
brauchen eigentlich eher ein
injektionsschutzgesetz als ein
Infektionsschutzgesetz wenn Sie weiter
hier als Bundesminister arbeiten wollen
also wir arbeiten daran ein
injektionsschutzgesetz auf den Weg zu
bringen der lauterbach
wir haben reden heute auch über die
Ausnahmevorschriften im Bereich der
Geschäftsordnung der parlamentarische
Ausnahmezustand soll der fortgesetzt
werden obwohl die Pandemie weitestgehend
vorbei ist der 126a der Geschäftsordnung
soll erstmal bis Juli verlängert werden
sie haben sich bequem eingerichtet was
die Arbeit in den Ausschüssen angeht das
kann man inzwischen zu Hause vom Sofa
ausmachen man kann sich zuschalten
lassen und kriegt trotzdem die Trich
trotzdem die anwesenheitsbescheinigt wir
sagen weg damit freiheitstag nicht nur
in Deutschland freiheitstag auch im
Deutschen Bundestag wir brauchen im
Deutschen Bundestag genauso wenig wie in
der gesamten Republik keine
Ausnahmevorschriften mehr zurück zur
Normalität das funktioniert nur mit der
Freiheitspartei nur mit der Alternative
für Deutschland nur mit der Fraktion der
Alternative für Deutschland in diesem
Bundestag deshalb
lehnen wir die Verlängerung der
ausnahmeforschung des über 126a der
Geschäftsordnung ab und der Lauterbach
ich erwarte jetzt von ihnen die
Entschuldigung
zur zartbeseitet oder er flüchtet
erweiterte von ihnen die Entschuldigung
die können Sie auch gerne von da
ausmachen
und da bin ich zufrieden Danke schön
[Applaus]
lauterbach
[Musik]
also dazu meldet dann der
Geschäftsführer und entsprechend die
persönliche Erklärung an
so
gut
bei nächster Gelegenheit bitte ich
einfach rechtzeitig um das entsprechende
Zeichen es kommt jetzt die angekündigte
Regelung zur Anwendung dass bei
persönlicher Ansprache auch die
Kurzintervention möglich ist in dem Fall
hat Herr Lauterbach jetzt das Wort
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsident ich möchte
einfach für uns alle für die
demokratischen Parteien die ihr sprechen
möchte ich sagen wir möchten wir wollen
uns hier nicht als Lügner diffamieren
lassen das ist möchten das einfach nicht
wir möchten es wir möchten uns nicht als
Lügner diffamieren Streit in der Sache
jederzeit aber hier haben
unterschiedliche Meinungen aber hier
sprechen was die demokratischen Parteien
hat hier sprechen keine Lügner
[Applaus]
ein Lügner ist in meinen Augen jemand
der mindestens einmal die Unwahrheit
sagt obwohl die Wahrheit kennt er hat
einfach sie erzählen uns seit zwei
Jahren am laufenden Band die Unwahrheit
obwohl sie die Wahrheit wahrscheinlich
kennen
also seien Sie froh dass ich sie
lediglich als Lügner bezeichnet habe und
nicht noch andere Wörter gewählt habe
vielen Dank
so dann haben wir das
im Protokoll entsprechend vermerkt
und wir fahren in der Debatte fort das
Wort hat die Kollegen Christina
Aschenberg dugnos für die FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das was der
Herr Brantner hier eben gemacht hat ist
unanständig meine Damen und Herren das
gehört sich nicht in diesem Deutschen
Bundestag es ist unglaublich was sie
sich hier leisten
und in der ersten Rede der AFD wurde
behauptet es sei zu keiner Zeit zu einer
Überlastung der Krankenhäuser gekommen
auch das ist eine Unwahrheit was sie
hier behaupten wir haben noch vor kurzem
die Patienten aus einzelnen
Krankenhäusern ausgeflogen in andere
Krankenhäuser weil sie überlastet waren
insofern erzählen sie auch die
Unwahrheit hier und
benehmen sie sich einfach anständig und
kollegial und da wären wir schon
zufrieden mehr erwarten wir von Ihnen
gar nicht so liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich wiederhole es immer wieder
gebetsmühlenartig
selbstverständlich ist die Pandemie noch
nicht vorbei aber die Situation ist eine
andere als wir sie noch vor zwei Jahren
hatten
wir sind weit entfernt vor den von den
Zuständen die wir hatten und deswegen
müssen wir eben auch andere Maßnahmen
ergreifen als wir sie vor zwei Jahren
hatten wir müssen lernen mit dem Virus
zu leben denn wir werden das Virus so
schnell nicht los meine Damen und Herren
und deswegen sind die geplanten
vorliegenden Änderungen im
Infektionsschutzgesetz ein wichtiger
Schritt in Richtung Normalität aber bei
gleichzeitiger Handlungsfähigkeit und
das ist doch das wichtige an der ganzen
Sache
das oberste Ziel der pandemiebekämpfung
war und ist es immer eine Überlastung
des Gesundheitswesens zu verhindern und
vor allem unsere vulnerablen Gruppen zu
schützen und genau das setzen wir mit
diesem Gesetz um wir müssen angemessen
und zielgerichtet agieren meine Damen
und Herren und wir schaffen ja auch
nicht
alle für behauptet wird in bestimmten
Bereichen die in Krankenhäusern alten
und Pflegeeinrichtungen Einrichtung für
Menschen mit Behinderung da wird
weiterhin mit Tests und Masken
gearbeitet meine Damen und Herren und an
einzelnen Stellen haben wir auch
nachgeschärft beispielsweise dass auch
in Arztpraxen Masken getragen werden
müssen aber völlig anders sieht es im
Bereich der Schulen und
Kindertagesstätten aus es macht doch
einen Unterschied ob sich jüngere
infizieren oder Risikopatienten und
diesen Unterschied müssen wir auch bei
den Maßnahmen abbilden denn Kinder haben
glücklicherweise ein wesentlich milderen
Verlauf bei der omegonvariante und wir
wissen doch was mit unseren
[Musik]
Frage oder Bemerkung der Kollegin
Lindholz
welche Fraktion ein cdu/csu ach da
Entschuldigung ja gerne
ja erstmal liebe Frau Aschenbrenner
dudnuss vielen Dank für die Zulassung
der Zwischenfrage
ich habe ihren Ausführungen schon
diese Woche beim letzten Mal zugehört
und auch heute wieder und ich würde
Ihnen gerne eine ein Fall schildern und
fragen was wir diesen Personen antworten
sollen
sie sagen ja immer sie schaffen die
maskenpflicht nicht ganz ab sie lassen
sie ihm krank in Krankenhäusern weiter
zu sie lassen sie im öffentlichen
Personen Nahverkehr weiter bestehen sie
lassen sie aber zum Beispiel nicht
weiter bestehen im Bereich des
öffentlichen Lebens im Supermarkt und
das lassen sie auch nicht über den April
hinaus bestehen und wir haben eine
Inzidenz die heute bei aktuell
1600 irgendwas liegt also nahe 1.700 wir
haben 280 Todesfälle was sagen sie einer
Krebskranken oder anders schwerkranken
jungen Frau alten Frau ein Mann also
einer Person die alles umgehen kann die
nicht in der Gaststätte gehen muss
die vielleicht auch
sich nicht privat groß treffen muss die
aber zumindest zum Einkaufen gehen muss
und beim Einkaufen diese Frau versucht
alles dieser Mann diese Person um sich
nicht zu infizieren weil er sich mitten
in einer Krebstherapie befindet was
sagen sie dieser Person die möchte in
Zukunft in den Supermarkt gehen nach wie
vor und sie möchten in Zukunft geschützt
werden aber sie ist in Zukunft nicht
mehr geschützt sie selber kann ihre
Maske aufziehen das stimmt aber ihr
gegenüber ihr gegenüber muss die Maske
im öffentlichen Personennahverkehr noch
aufziehen aber nicht im Supermarkt was
sagen sie einer solchen Person der wir
bei den jetzigen Inzidenzen und
Todeszahlen die maskenpflicht mit der
maskenpflicht den Schutz wegnehmen und
die Kollegen von der FDP ich höre den
Zwischenruf jedes Mal und deswegen führe
ich länger aus ja sie kann die Maske
freiwillig aufsetzen aber ihr Gegenüber
nicht und ein wirksamer Schutz Liebe
waschenberg ducknuss in liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der FDP
erfordert ist dass beide Personen eine
Maske aufziehen ich frage Sie jetzt wie
sie bei diesen Inzidenzen das gegenüber
diesen vulnerablen Personen vertreten
können
sehr geehrte Frau Kollegin genau das
also Entschuldigung bin ich jetzt dran
oder nicht jetzt
Kollegin Lindholz das Mikrofon ist aus
die Frage ist verstanden und jetzt hat
die Kollegin Aschenberg dugnos das Wort
für die Beantwortung vielen Dank für
Ihre Frage die wir ja häufiger von Ihnen
hören und der von ihnen geschuldet
geschilderte Fall würde ich sagen bitte
setzen Sie die Maske auf den eine
ffp2-maske hat
nachweisbar einen drei vierfachen Schutz
und ist völlig ausreichend um sich im
Leben bewegen zu können und das können
Sie diesen dieser Dame oder diesem Herr
auch sagen und dann gehen sie immer von
den Inzidenzen aus Sie müssen doch
konstatieren dass wir jetzt einen
Unterschied haben wir haben wahnsinnig
hohe Fallzahlen aber auch heute wieder
wenn sie auf den RKI Dashboard gehen
sehen sie dass auch die
Intensivpatienten die Zahl abgenommen
hat das heißt bei Risiken Inzidenzen
haben wir weniger Fälle auf den
Intensivstationen das heißt das Virus
ist milder im Verlauf und erzählen sie
den Leuten doch mal was positives dass
sie sich mit Masken schützen können und
dass wir zum Beispiel wenn Sie auf den
RKI Bericht gehen auch wesentlich
weniger Todesfälle haben als noch in der
vierten Welle als wir jetzt fast 3000
Todesfälle pro Woche hatten da sind wir
doch weit von entfernt sagen Sie das
doch mal den Leuten dass sie auch sagen
können sie können sich schützen aber Sie
können auch am Leben teilnehmen als hier
solche Horrorszenarien immer
aufzuspielen wir müssen nur Perspektiven
für die Menschen geben wir müssen doch
sagen es geht weiter ihr könnt wieder
etwas tun und wenn sie jetzt vom
Einkaufen reden ich weiß sie wollen alle
staatlich vorschreiben in meinem
Heimatort Strande war es schon längst
üblich da wo viele ältere sind da gibt
es da kann man zum Beispiel vor Ort auch
extra Einkaufszeiten machen dann geht
man als
älterer Mensch mit Maske dahin und hat
spezielle Einkaufszeiten es gibt so
viele Möglichkeiten zu agieren aber wir
müssen doch auch sehen dass in
bestimmten Bereichen und dazu komme ich
noch zum Beispiel bei den Kindern das
ist doch gerade fahrlässig ist damit
einer maskenpflicht zu arbeiten das geht
doch nicht und wir können doch jetzt
nicht die die Bildungschancen die
sozialen Chancen unserer Kinder
aufrechnen gegen die vulnerablen Gruppen
mit unserem Gesetz schützen wir die
vulnerablen Gruppen aber bieten unseren
Kindern und Jugendlichen auch die
Möglichkeit Bildung zu erlangen soziales
Leben zu erlangen und das ist doch genau
das was wir wollen Frau Kollegin
und deswegen aus meinem eben
ausgeführten können sie hören dass uns
eben dabei eine Frage je Rede
Kollegen Lindholz ich habe heute zu
Beginn unserer Debatte die geltenden
Regeln die wir seit Mittwoch auch
durchhalten erläutert wir lassen je Rede
eine Frage und Antwort zu nach wie vor
ist die Zeit nicht limitiert das ist
denke ich jetzt auch
beantwortet und jetzt bitte ich hier in
der Debatte vorzufahren
denn ich fahre fort aus dem eben gesagt
oder können Sie heraushören wie wichtig
uns die Bildungschancen und unsere
Kinder sind indem wir sie eben nicht
mehr dazu zwingen Maske zu tragen und
damit sind wir auch mit vielen
Kinderpsychologen einer Meinung viele
Kinderärzte fordern das auch dass es
also nicht nur die FDP ach und überhaupt
der Kollege Wiese hat es ja geschildert
Herr Söder schafft er jetzt die
maskenpflicht auch ab in den
Grundschulen also so schlecht kann unser
Gesetz doch gar nicht sein auf der einen
Seite fordern Sie allgemeine
maskenpflicht aber wenn es dann zum
Schwur kommt agieren sie doch anders wie
zum Beispiel Herr Söder also bei ihnen
stimmt auch in der Argumentation ganz
vieles nicht meine Damen und Herren so
und jetzt noch mal zu Omicron sie hat
nun mal andere Folgen als die Delta
Variante und deswegen müssen wir eben
auch um andere Maßnahmen ergreifen und
ich möchte abschließend noch mal betonen
und das ist das Positive wir sind doch
den Virus nicht hilflos ausgesetzt wir
haben gut funktionierende Impfung
deswegen lassen sie sich impfen und
lassen sie sich Boostern wir haben
Medikamente aber was ich sagen muss wir
laufen leider immer der Entwicklung
hinterher und deswegen werden wir als
Koalition jetzt auch ein Frühwarnsystem
auf den Weg bringen das ist uns als FDP
ganz besonders wichtig mit mit einem
abwassermonitoring oder zum Beispiel mit
repräsentativen Studien damit wir genau
wissen was im Herbst Winter auf uns
zukommt und und um dann mit diesem
Gesetz zielgerichtet zu agieren das sind
wir der Bevölkerung schuldig
zielgerichtet und nicht einfach hier so
querbeet danke schön für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
zu seiner ersten Rede im Deutschen
Bundestag hat nun der Kollege Matthias
Papendiek für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kolleginnen als
erstes möchte ich erstmal
Genesungswünsche ausrichten an unseren
Kollegen Manuel Gaber er ist leider an
Corona erkrankt er hätte heute diese
Rede gehalten
wir beraten heute neben einer Änderung
des Infektionsschutzgesetzes auch das
sozial-dienstleister-einsatzgesetz
dessen Verlängerung und weitere
Regelungen dieses leistet und bereits
seit Beginn der Pandemie wertvolle
Dienste in dem es in Einsatz von
sozialen Dienstleistern zur
Krisenbewältigung sichert und die
wirtschaftliche Leistungsfähigkeit
aufrecht erhält die sozialen
Dienstleister hierzu zählen
beispielsweise die Werkstätten von
Menschen mit Behinderung Reha und
Versorgungseinrichtungen sowie die
Anbieter von Sprachkursen leisten bei
der gesellschaftlichen Krisenbewältigung
unverzichtbarer Arbeit und stellen daher
eine wichtige Säule der
pandemiebekämpfung da die
die den Bestand unserer sozialen
Infrastrukturen maßgeblich gesichert
leider ist die Pandemie immer noch nicht
überwunden so dass auch die sozialen
Dienstleister corona-bedingt
wirtschaftliche Belastungen unterliegen
und daher weiterhin auf finanzielle
Unterstützung angewiesen sind die
Situation der sind der sozialen
Dienstleister stark von weiteren
infektionsschutzmaßnahmen abhängig und
somit mit Ungewissheit und großer
Unsicherheit verbunden mit dem solek
steht uns ein wichtiges effektives
Instrument zur Verfügung das dazu
geeignet ist die Unsicherheiten
aufzufangen und damit die Wicht ein
wichtiges politisches Signal zu setzen
das in einer unsicheren Zeit
Beständigkeit und Sicherheit vermittelt
auch wenn damit zu rechnen ist dass die
Infektionszahlen während der
Sommermonate wieder rückläufig sein
werden
ist es wichtig dass wir gerade auch im
Hinblick auf Unsicherheiten bzw
möglicherweise neu auftauchende
Virusvarianten oder bevorstehende
Urlaubssaison mit Umsicht und
vorausschauend handeln und
handlungsfähig bleiben
dabei ist jedoch zu betonen dass die
Verlängerung des sodex keine
finanziellen Belastungen ausgeben sofern
keine weiteren Maßnahmen nach
Infektionsschutzgesetz
ergriffen werden müssen die Verlängerung
des Solex erhalten wir nicht nur eine
wichtige Rechtsgrundlage aufrecht die es
den Leistungsträgern weiterhin
ermöglicht Zahlungen an den sozialen
Dienstleistern zu leisten sondern
sichern zugleich auch eine Reihe von
Maßnahmen die sich in Vergangenheit
bewährt gemacht haben die zu
beschließenden Maßnahmen Enden
spätestens am 23 September 2022 und zu
erreichen dass das Ende September
tatsächlich eine weitere Maßnahme nicht
notwendig sind ist unser wichtiges
Mittel die corona-schutzimpfung unser
uns stehen in Deutschland nicht nur
sichere sondern auch wirksame Impfstoffe
zur Verfügung
nach wie vor sind die Impfquoten nicht
hoch genug gerade deshalb ist es auch
weiterhin besonders wichtig denn
Augenmerk auf betriebliche
infektionsschutzmaßnahmen zu legen um
sichere Arbeitsbedingungen zu
gewährleisten für die Kolleginnen und
Kolleginnen hierzu zählen vor allen
Dingen auch die aha-regeln Testungen
sowie das Angebot von Impfungen gerade
die ihre Maßnahmen haben sich in
Vergangenheit Vergangenheit mit großen
Nutzen bewährt mit der Verlängerung des
Solex wird darüber hinaus dafür Sorge
getragen dass pandemiebedingte soziale
Risiken abgefedert werden dass die
Erhöhung der kinderkrankentage zum
Beispiel von zehn auf 30 Tagen wie
Lebensqualität von erwerbstätigen Eltern
entspricht haben wir gesehen daran dass
er die Krankenkassen in 2021 mehr als
doppelt so viele Anträge verzeichneten
wie noch in 2020 auch in den kommenden
Monaten muss damit gerechnet werden dass
Kinder sich auch wenn Sie nicht selbst
erkrankt sind in Isolation oder
Quarantäne begeben müssen die
Fortschreibung der Erhöhung der
kinderkrankentage natürlich unerlässlich
damit Kinder damit Eltern ihre Kinder
pflegen und betreuen können
die Erhöhung der kinderkrankentage war
zwar aus Anlass der Pandemie eingeführt
allerdings habe ich auch als Vater einer
mittlerweile fünf Jahre alten Tochter
die Erfahrung gemacht dass die
bisherigen Anzahl der kinderkranken Tage
vor allen Dingen während der Kita
Eingewöhnungszeit nicht ausreichte auch
unabhängig von der Pandemie Lage wäre
einer Höhe dieser wünschenswert
nicht nur im Hinblick auf die
coronakrise gilt dass wir dafür Sorge
tragen müssen dass alle Menschen die
darauf angewiesen sind ausreichende
Unterstützung erhalten und Rückhalt
durch den Sozialstaat erfahren
die in vielen Jahrzehnten gewachsen
soziale Infrastruktur ist das Thema
relevant und muss daher gerade jetzt in
den Zeiten der Krise besonders
unterstützt werden im Verlauf der
Pandemie konnten durch die finanzielle
Unterstützung nach dem
sozialdienstleister einsatzgesetz
zahlreiche sozialen Dienstleister wie
zum Beispiel Rehakliniken oder
Vorsorgeeinrichtungen vor der Schließung
bewahrt werden dieser Status gilt es zu
erhalten die Verlängerung des
sozialdienstleistansatzes ist daher
unverzichtbar zum Schluss meiner Rede
bleibt es mir zu bitten um Zustimmung zu
dieser Vorlage
[Applaus]
für die cdu/csu-fraktion hat nun die
Kollegin Emmi Zöllner
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zuerst liebe
Frau Kolleginnen von der FDP bin ich in
unserem bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten
Markus Söder sehr dankbar dass er die
maskenpflicht in den Grundschulen
abschafft wir lassen die Kinder dort in
den Schulen nicht alleine
denn mit
regelmäßigen Tests und auch mit
Lüftungsanlagen die durchaus regelmäßig
in den Schulen vorhanden sind schaffen
wir eine nötigen Schutz und gleichzeitig
gehen wir auf die Bedürfnisse der Kinder
ein denn es ist klar so dass wenn der
Spracherwerb und er ist in der
Grundschule besonders im Fokus getätigt
werden muss ist es entscheidend dem
Gegenüber ins Gesicht schauen zu können
auf die Mundbewegungen schauen zu können
und deshalb bin ich sehr froh dass wir
in Bayern diesen Schritt abgewogen
gegangen sind nichtsdestotrotz sind sie
natürlich sehr im konsequent in ihrer
Argumentation denn wenn auf der einen
Seite der Bundesminister Lauterbach eben
seine gesetzliche Regelung darstellt
dass eben Hotspots auch ganze
Bundesländer betrifft und gleichzeitig
sie als FDP davon sprechen dass nur
einzelne Landkreise betroffen sein
könnten dann passt da was nicht zusammen
sie sind nicht eins in der
Ampelkoalition und das lassen wir Ihnen
auch nicht durchgehen und nicht
durchgehen lassen Ihnen das auch die
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder und das
sind also mit Verlaub nicht nur
unionsgeführte Länder dabei sondern
natürlich auch die
landesministerpräsidenten von SPD und
mit natürlich Beteiligung auch der FDP
deswegen ist passt in ihrem Gesetz ganz
offensichtlich etwas nicht zusammen und
auch in den Maßnahmen passen Dinge nicht
zusammen denn sie geben auf der einen
Seite weiterhin Warnungen aus und
gleichzeitig schaffen Sie beispielsweise
die Unterstützungen die
versorgungsaufschläge
Ausgleichszahlungen für Krankenhäusern
für Arztpraxen ab auch damit lassen sie
gerade Krankenhäusern im ländlichen Raum
Arztpraxen im Regen stehen und das geht
in einer Reihe damit und deswegen haben
wir als Union auch einen Änderungsantrag
eingebracht den sie wahrscheinlich nicht
gelesen haben aber ich werbe sehr dafür
das zu tun nämlich dass wir eben auch
Bonuszahlungen für die fordern die eben
die Notaufnahme leer gehalten haben und
das der Pflege Bonus das wurde
kritisiert von unserem
Gesundheitsminister hollitschek aber
auch vom Kollegen Czaja dass er immer
noch nicht auf den Weg gebracht wurde
das ist ein Skandal das ist
Arbeitsverweigerung was sie hier tun und
das bei diesem
pflegebonus wir jetzt angedacht ist das
soll die medizinischen Fachangestellten
zahnmedizinischen Fachangestellten und
auch Mitarbeiter im Rettungswesen keine
Berücksichtigung finden auch das finde
ich empörend denn auch sie waren es
die maßgeblich dazu beigetragen haben
dass die Impfkampagne funktioniert hat
dass die Leute schnell von A nach B
gekommen sind dass die Leute in der
Quarantäne nicht einfach ab mit
administriert wurden sondern dass sie
Ansprechpartner hatten und deswegen
gehört es sich meiner Meinung nach dass
wir diesen Bonus einführen nicht nur für
die Pflege auch für die Mitarbeiter im
Rettungswesen auch für die medizinischen
Fachangestellten und deswegen fordere
ich Sie ganz konkret aus gehen Sie mit
uns einen Schritt weiter
fortschrittskoalition wir wollen Zukunft
gestalten wir wollen einen
bund-ländergipfel für die Reform der
Ausbildung der Medizinischen
Fachangestellten das betrifft rund
500.000 vor allem Frauen in unserem Land
da müssen wir handeln da müssen wir
Zukunft gestalten und deswegen lesen Sie
den Antrag der Unionsfraktion durch und
schaffen Sie mit uns gemeinsam einen
Bonus der über dem pflegebonus
hinausgeht danke
[Applaus]
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
hat nun der Kollege Helge Limburg das
Wort
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Frau
Kollegin Zeuner 1 habe ich nicht
verstanden nach ihrer Vorbemerkung den
verständlichen Wunsch dass die
maskenpflicht in Grundschulen Fällen zu
begrüßen und anschließend das Gesetz was
genau diesen Wunsch erst ermöglicht
abzulehnen das passt für mich nicht
zusammen
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen viele Menschen möchten endlich
ohne Impfnachweis und ohne Maske
einkaufen ohne Masken Theater oder Kino
sitzen oder Frau Zahnarzt gesagt ohne
Maske in der Schule sitzen und dieser
Wunsch ist verständlich der muss auch
nicht gerechtfertigt oder begründet
werden ein freier demokratischer
Rechtsstaat darauf hat der Köder zu
Recht hingewiesen muss jede
grundrechtseinschränkung begründen und
nicht die Bürgerinnen und Bürger müssen
begründen warum sie keine Maske gefragt
werden aber genauso verständlich und
legitim ist eben auch der Wunsch von
Menschen und zwar auch von Menschen mit
Vorerkrankungen von Wohlen rabengruppen
und anderen am sozialen Leben teilhaben
zu können zum Beispiel im Supermarkt
oder anderen Geschäften einkaufen zu
können ohne die Sorge haben zu müssen
sich dabei mit dem Coronavirus zu
infizieren
auch die können sich auf Pflichten des
Staates nämlich auf Schutzpflichten
Berufen natürlich kann es ein
Komplettschutz nicht geben aber ich kann
schon die Leute verstehen die sagen naja
müsst ihr angesichts dieser doch sehr
hohen Infektionen Zahlen wo die
Wahrscheinlichkeit sich anzustecken ja
doch relativ groß ist denn gerade solche
Lockerungen vornehmen insofern ist es
kein Geheimnis verkörpert hat der
autotherm ist gesagt dass ich meine
Fraktion eine weitergehende
maskenpflicht in Innenräumen sehr gut
hätte vorstellen können und das ist dazu
verschiedene Sichtweisen in der
Ampelkoalition gibt aber richtig ist
eben auch und darauf ist zu Recht
hingewiesen worden es ist nicht so dass
dieser Gesetzentwurf keine Maßnahmen
mehr ermöglicht die hotspot-regelung die
unter Beteiligung der jeweiligen Landtag
und das ist doch beste föderale
demokratische Tradition mit Zustimmung
der Landtage geschaffen wird ermöglicht
eben weitergehende Maßnahmen zum
Beispiel die von Ihnen geforderten
maskenpflichten auch in Innenräumen und
ich finde es da schon sehr wichtig was
der Kollege Wiese gesagt hat wir sollten
ja ein deutscher Kunden gestatten Sie
eine Frage oder Bemerkung aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion von denen schon
ich meinte von der demokratischen
Richtung
vielen Dank
für ihre Ausführung zur hotspot-regelung
wir haben bereits in der ersten Lesung
im Deutschen Bundestag als auch heute
unterschiedliche Auffassungen aus der
Ampelkoalition zum Thema Hotspot gehört
es fehlen nur noch die Ausführung der
Grünen der Bundesgesundheitsminister hat
gesagt hotspotte können ganze Länder
sein auch die Kollegin aus der SPD hat
in der ersten Lesung gesagt hotspotte
können ganze Länder sein ganze
Bundesländer wie beispielsweise
Schleswig-Holstein Sachsen-Anhalt
Baden-Württemberg die Freien Demokraten
sagen die Gebietskörperschaft ist der
Landkreis vollkommen allein jetzt frage
ich sie wie sehen Bündnis 90 die Grünen
das bei diesen Inzidenzen bei diesen
krankheitsbelastungen wie ist die
grenzscharfe Abgrenzung eines Hotspots
sind das ganze Bundesländer
flächenbundesländer oder sind das
lediglich kleine Städte und kleine
Landkreise
vielen Dank lieber Herr Kollege für die
Frage weil es mir in der Tat ermöglicht
einen wichtigen Aspekten der Debatte
noch mal näher zu erläutern sie kennen
genau wie ich den Spruch ein Blick ins
Gesicht erleichtern ins Gesetz
erleichtert die Rechtsfindung und im
Gesetz
und
und im gesetzlichen der Tat von
Gebietskörperschaften die Rede sie
wissen das Gebietskörperschaften Städte
sein können Gemeinde sein können
Landkreise sein können aber das
natürlich auch Länder
Gebietskörperschaften sind und insofern
das ist das ist ihnen ja nichts Neues
und insofern geht das Gesetz mit dem
unbestimmten Rechtsbegriffen die die
Kriterien darstellen ist ja nicht nur
ein Kriterium sind verschiedene
Kriterien angelegt aufgrund welcher
unbestimmten Rechtsbegriffe einen
Hotspot festgestellt werden kann
natürlich wird es im Regelfall so sein
wenn sie sich die Inzidenzen auf die
krankenhausbewegung andere Situation
unserem Land anschauen das im Regelfall
Hotspots auf Landkreise oder Regionen
begrenzt sind aber natürlich ist nicht
ausgeschlossen im Gesetz wenn sie
insbesondere an die Bundesländer Hamburg
Bremen oder auch das Saarland denken
oder auch in besonderen Situationen an
weitere Bundesländer das ein ganzes
Bundesland zum Hotspot erklärt wird aber
Herr Kollege diese Entscheidung und das
finde ich ausdrücklich richtig obliegt
den dafür gewählten Landesparlamenten
wir als Deutscher Bundestag und die
Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidenten sollten sich davor
hüten die Arbeit der Landesparlamente
gering zu schätzen ich weiß aus eigener
Erfahrung ich teil das ja mit vielen
Kolleginnen Kollegen hier im Haus wie
professionell dort gearbeitet wird und
darum ist es dort im richtigen Händen
liebe
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich habe es jetzt mehrfach ausgeführt
wir hätten uns weitergehende Maßnahmen
vorstellen können aber politik ist immer
auch die die Kunst der Kompromissfindung
und wir haben ja ein Kompromiss gefunden
der handhabbar und händelbar ist der den
Landtagen viel Verantwortung überträgt
für die sie auch gewählt finden Sie auch
gewählt sind und wir haben aber das ist
mir noch wichtig zu betonen am Ende wir
haben die klare Vereinbarung in der
Ampelkoalition und es gibt nach der
bisherigen Zusammenarbeit auch keinen
Zweifel daran dass diese Vereinbarung
geht dass wenn wir feststellen Kollege
Köhler hat sie auch noch mal gesagt wenn
wir feststellen dass die heute zu
beschließen den Regelungen dann eben
doch nicht ausreichen wenn wir
feststellen dass die Sorgen die viele
hier in der heutigen Debatte geäußert
haben und die Menschen draußen äußern
dass die berechtigt sind dann werden wir
natürlich als Ampelkoalition als
gesamter Bundestag schnell noch mal
zusammentreten und gegebenenfalls
nachbessern liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen normalerweise hofft man als
Politiker ja dass man recht behält ich
muss Ihnen offen sagen heute hoffe ich
dass die Kollegin capacontas Kollege
audritsch und ich uns irren und wir mit
unseren Befürchtungen und Sorgen nicht
recht behalten aber wie gesagt wenn es
so ist dass diese Regelung
wenn es so ist dass diese Regelung nicht
ausreichen dann werden wir hier schnell
noch mal zusammenkommen diese
Handlungsfähigkeit haben wir in den
vergangenen Monaten bewiesen und wir
werden sie auch in den kommenden Monaten
an den Tag legen vielen
[Applaus]
während des Pult hierher gerichtet wird
sei mir letztes malig der Hinweis
gestattet wenn Sie eine
mund-nasen-bedeckung sprich eine
ffp-2-maske anlegen müssen auch Mund und
Nase bedeckt sein und da wir ja gerade
über die Wirksamkeit dieser Masken hier
auch gesprochen haben dazu gehört eben
auch dass sie nicht nur äußerlich
bedeckt sind sondern dass die Maske auch
fachgerecht angelegt wird das heißt auch
die entsprechenden Bügel über die Ohren
gezogen werden oder eine entsprechende
Vorrichtung dafür sorgt dass die Maske
tatsächlich schließt ich dachte das wäre
inzwischen Allgemeinwissen aber
augenscheinlich ist es notwendig das
gelegentlich zu wiederholen
so und jetzt fahren wir in der Debatte
fort
das Wort hat die Kollegin Diana Stöcke
für die CDU-Fraktion im Übrigen hätte
ich gern sollten die Zwischenrufe die
gerade meinen Hinweis
kommentiert haben dokumentiert sein
behalte ich mir vor auch zu bewerten
inwieweit das eine unzulässige Kritik an
der Verhandlungsführung hier im
Präsidium war
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir alle wissen
es seit Monaten morgen am 19.03 läuft es
Infektionsschutzgesetz aus es gab
keinerlei vorausschauende Vorbereitung
der Ampelkoalition in einem
herumverfahren muss das Gesetz in fünf
Tagen durchgezogen werden im Ergebnis
und ein handwerklich schlechtes nicht
ausgereiftes Konzept das von Experten in
der öffentlichen Anhörung am letzten
Montag auseinandergenommen wurde von und
von ihnen bis heute nicht wesentlich
nachgebessert wurde ein solch schlechten
Gesetzesentwurf können wir als
Unionsfraktion nur ablehnen
auch die Bundesländer sprechen sich
mehrheitlich dieses Gesetz aus war
vorhin schon ein paar mal die Rede davon
in kündigen bereits jetzt an dass sie
den aktuellen Handlungsoptionen so lange
nutzen werden wie es irgend möglich ist
um die Pandemie zu bekämpfen in der
öffentlichen Debatte am Mittwoch und
auch heute wieder haben wir Abgeordnete
ihrer Regierungskoalition gehört die
gesagt haben dass das neue
Infektionsschutzgesetz ein großer
Kompromiss sei der die ampelkreation
abbildet sie hätten sich ein anderes
Gesetz gewünscht würden den Ländern gern
einen breiteren instrumentenkatalog zur
Verfügung stellen aber diese
minimal-lösung sei eben Demokratie
sprich es ist der kleinste gemeinsame
Nenner der in ihrer Koalition möglich
ist
diesen Satz werden wir meine Prognose
noch öfter hören
demokratie heißt aber nicht nur einen
Minimalkonsens in einer
Regierungskoalition herzustellen sondern
mit Verantwortung und Vernunft
Entscheidungen zu treffen und zu handeln
Minister Habeck sagte gestern bei seinem
Statement zu Impfpflicht in Vorsorge und
Verantwortung denken aber beim
Infektionsschutzgesetz gilt es plötzlich
nicht mehr sie haben die Pflicht ältere
und immunschwache Menschen zu schützen
aber sie heben die maskenpflicht
weitgehend auf schaffen einen
Flickenteppich und mit einer schwammigen
hotspots-strategie wo gehobelt wird
fallen Späne aber bei ihnen fällt
sprichwörtlich buchstäblich der ganze
komplette Werkzeugkasten auseinander
am Mittwoch habe ich mit dem Leiter des
welcome Centers für geflüchtete aus der
Ukraine im Berliner Hauptbahnhof
gesprochen er berichtete jeder dritte
der bislang 150.000 geflüchteten aus der
Ukraine hat ist positiv auf Corona
getestet Menschen die in überfüllten
Zügen unterwegs waren und nun in
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften Zusammenleben
und in dieser Krise wird das
Infektionsschutzgesetz auf ein Minimum
reduziert nehmen sie von der
Ampelkoalition diesen Widerspruch
überhaupt wahr
wir befinden uns im krisenmodus schon in
normalen Zeiten hat es sich nie
ausgezahlt abzuwarten aber die aktuelle
zögerliche Haltung das ständige auf der
Bremse stehen wenn es um
vorausschauendes zupackendes Handeln
halt er handeln geht wird Ihnen auf die
Füße fallen sie sind sehenden Auges in
diese Situation reingerasselt und sie
werden mit dem Gesetzesentwurf ihrer
Verantwortung gegenüber der Bevölkerung
nicht gerecht
[Applaus]
das Wort hat der Kollege Jens peik für
die spd-brücke
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren heute
diskutieren wir das
Infektionsschutzgesetz sowie weitere
gesetzliche Regelungen zu einer dieser
Regelungen die Verbesserung beim
Kurzarbeitergeld möchte ich für meine
Fraktion hier was sagen weil für die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer in
unserem Land gerade in der jetzigen
Situation von besonderer Bedeutung ist
vor vier Wochen haben wir hier im Haus
die Verlängerung der krisenbedingten
Sonderregelung ist kurzarbeitergeltes im
Grundsatz beschlossen vor vier Wochen
bestand auch noch die vorsichtige
Zuversicht dass eine Erholung auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt gibt und dass wir nicht
alle Sonderregelungen die wenn der
corona-krise hatten weiter verlängern
müssen dass wir uns auf dem Weg zur
Normalität befinden
sechs Tage später mit dem Überfall
Putins auf die Ukraine ist eine Rückkehr
zur Normalität in weite Ferne gerückt
Präsident selenski hat das hier gestern
in diesem Haus sehr eindrücklich
geschildert und die Schrecken des
Krieges deutlich gemacht
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir handeln
die Bundesregierung hat umfangreiche
Sanktionen gegen das System Putin auf
dem Weg gebracht das war notwendig und
das war richtig
aber Krieg und Sanktionen werden auch an
uns nicht spurlos vorbeigehen es fehlen
Rohstoffe wegen mangelnder Halbleiter
und Kabelbäume musste die Autoindustrie
bereits Industrie drosseln in Teilen
einstellen es wird davon Ausgangs bis
Juni 400.000 bis 1,5 Millionen Fahrzeuge
das entspricht 10 bis 40 Prozent
jährliche Produktion weniger produziert
werden können heute morgen ging noch
über die Ticker dass das Baugewerbe
Materialmangel hat dieser Stillstand
kostet auch uns
aber eins darf auf keinen Fall Kosten
und das sind Arbeitsplätze
deswegen
gilt das was ich zu einem vor einem
Monat zur Grundüberzeugung dieser
Regierungskoalition gesagt habe auch
heute wir lassen niemand im Stich
deshalb werden wir die Leiharbeit mit
der Änderung die wir hier mit
beschließen wieder in das
Kurzarbeitergeld aufnehmen denn der
Ukraine Krieg ist kein branchenübliches
Risiko und die Automobilindustrie auf
den Einsatz von LeiharbeitnehmerInnen
und Arbeitnehmern angewiesen
Walter ermöglichen wir der
Bundesregierung bei außergewöhnlichen
Verhältnissen auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
schnell zu reagieren und per
Rechtsverordnung die
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge wieder
teilweise oder auch vollständig zu
erstatten denn es ist vollkommen klar
und wir sind uns einig wir alle können
nicht vorhersehen wie sich dieser
Konflikt entwickeln wird und was noch
auf uns zukommt mit dieser Maßnahme
stellen wir die Handlungsfähigkeit der
Bundesregierung im Ernstfall sicher in
Sozialpolitik darf nicht immer nur
hinten dranhängen und reparaturpolitik
sein sondern sie muss vorausschauend
agieren
und wir alle wissen
die Erstattung der
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge kann teuer
sein Bundesminister Heil hat in seiner
Rede vor vier Wochen hier deutlich
gemacht dass die 26 Milliarden Rücklage
der BA aufgebraucht sind Kurzarbeit hat
bisher 42 Milliarden Euro gekostet aber
uns auch eins wichtig ebenso wenig wie
bei der äußeren sicherheit darf man eine
sozialen Sicherheit und dem inneren
Zusammenhalt in unserem Land sparen
und deshalb
finde ich zum Schluss meiner Rede im
Blick noch einmal auf die nächste Woche
in der wir hier im Bundestag über den
Haushalt sprechen werden
und ich sage ganz deutlich wir dürfen
nicht nur auf die Ausgaben schauen
sondern auch auf die Einnahmen wir
brauchen Geld um diese Herausforderung
zu meistern da sage ich ganz klar starke
Schultern müssen mehr tragen als
schwache danke Ihnen für Ihre Zustimmung
für die cdu/csu-fraktion hat nun der
Kollege Wilfried Oehlers das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
auch wenn ja offensichtlich Uneinigkeit
über die lagebewertung besteht in diesem
Haus so scheint doch zumindest Einigkeit
darüber zu bestehen dass es
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen gibt die es gilt
zu verlängern so auch das
sozialdienstleister einsatzgesetzes dass
wir in der letzten Legislaturperiode
bereits auf den Weg gebracht haben und
das ja die Zielrichtung hatte gerade
Einrichtungen der
Arbeitsmarktpolitik der Rehabilitation
und der Behindertenhilfe finanziell zu
unterstützen damit sie aufgrund der
einschränkenden Maßnahmen die sie hatten
durch die corona-pandemie finanziell
nicht in die Schieflage geraten und auch
weiterhin bestehen können und das Gesetz
hat in seiner Wirkung auch gezeigt dass
es richtig war die es zu machen und dass
die Wirkungen auch entsprechend da waren
wenn man sieht dass etwa 25.000 Anträge
gestellt worden sind und die
allermeisten auch bewilligt worden sind
und die Einrichtungen eben nicht
schließen mussten sondern eben weiterhin
auch arbeiten können unter erschwerten
Maßnahmen aber auch existieren können so
war das unwahrscheinlich wichtig und
richtig dieses Gesetz damals zu machen
und auch wenn jetzt die
einschränkenden Maßnahmen vielleicht
zurückgenommen werden so steht ja aber
auch im Infektionen Schutzgesetz wenn
das die Länder ja gegebenenfalls ja die
Maßnahmen wieder aufgreifen können und
da jetzt Vorsorge zu betreiben damit
dieses Gesetz dann auch sofort wirken
kann wenn die Länder sich für solche
Schritte entscheiden halten wir von der
cdu/csu-fraktion für vollkommen richtig
und unterstützen damit auch diese
Verlängerung des sozialdienstleister
einsatzgesetzes neben
[Applaus]
neben dieser Maßnahme werden aber auch
weitere
corona-sonderregelungen durch
eine Verordnungsermächtigung eben auch
verlängert und das halten wir auch für
wichtige ich darf Sie in Kürze aufzählen
arbeitsschutzrechtliche Grundlagen für
betriebliche
infektionsmaßnahmen oder
coronabedingter Anpassungen von
Vergütungsvereinbarungen zwischen den
Trägern der zugelassenen Vorsorgung und
Rehabilitationseinrichtungen und den
Krankenkassen oder zum Beispiel den
Einsatz von Vorsorge und
Rehabilitationseinrichtungen als
ersatzkrankenhäuser bei
pandemiebedingter kapazitäts Engpässen
zugelassener Krankenhäuser das zeigt
dass der Maßnahmenkatalog vollumfänglich
erweitert wird und verlängert wird das
finden wir gut für die Zukunft hoffen
wir dass eine weitere Verlängerung jetzt
nicht nötig wäre weil das würde bedeuten
dass die Lage sich verbessert aber wenn
es doch absehbar weiß dass es eben nicht
der Fall ist dann bitten wir darum diese
verlängerungsgesetze vielleicht auch
frühzeitiger einzubringen herzlichen
Dank
[Applaus]
letzter Redner in dieser Debatte ist der
Kollege RWE Dudel für die CDU und
CSU-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren der vorliegende
Gesetzentwurf der Koalition macht
einigermaßen ratlos denn die Intention
ist grundsätzlich richtig im Gegensatz
zur Umsetzung natürlich ist es richtig
nach zwei Jahren
pandemiebedingter Einschränkung den Weg
zurück in die Normalität zu finden und
natürlich ist es sinnvoll weitere
Lockerungen zu beschließen und die
maskenpflicht zum Beispiel in Schule und
Kitas abzuschaffen die Verhältnisse
haben sich gravierend verändert wir
haben Impfstoffe wir haben Medikamente
und wir haben eine Mutation die milde
Verläufe
vorzeigt wir müssen lernen mit dem Virus
zu leben und die Einschränkungen im
Alltag müssen möglichst auf ein Minimum
reduziert werden so weit so gut aber
handwerklich ist der vorliegende Entwurf
eine Katastrophe
inhaltliche Unklarheiten und präzise
Formulierungen
unterschiedliche Interpretationen aus
der den Reihen der Koalition das alles
summiert sich zu einem Abbild der
Zerrissenheit der Ampel in dieser Frage
ob es um fehlende Definitionen für
Klinik Überlastung geht ob es um die
hotspot-regelung geht ob es um die Rolle
der Landtage geht überall fehlt es an
Klarheit und anschlüssigen Vorgaben die
Verlängerung der Übergangszeiten durch
diverse
Länder gibt bereits einen Vorgeschmack
auf das was uns künftig erwarten wird
verschlimmert wird alles nur noch durch
den Gesundheitsminister der trägt
zuverlässig zur weiteren Verunsicherung
der Menschen bei indem er den Kompromiss
der Koalition gleichzeitig lobt und
schlecht redet anstatt wenigsten zu
versuchen die mühsame Einigung der Ampel
verständlich zu kommunizieren redet der
Minister so als wenn er in Opposition zu
dem Antrag stehen würde so kann das
nicht weitergehen andere Länder in
Europa haben viel früher geöffnet doch
der Minister beschwört mit Vorliebe
unseren angeblich schlechten
corona-status übrigens in seiner
Amtszeit unser Gesundheitssystem
verkraftet auch das weil die Residenz
eben nicht gleichbedeutend ist mit
Überforderung
entscheidend ist die tatsächliche
Belastung des Gesundheitssystems meine
Damen und Herren
ich bin grundsätzlich für mehr Mut und
für mehr Freiheit in Eigenverantwortung
deshalb hätte ich gern diesem Antrag
zugestimmt der vorliegende Entwurf macht
es mir aber leider unmöglich
[Applaus]
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den von den
Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes und anderer
Vorschriften der Ausschuss für
Gesundheit empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf den Drucksachen
1070 und
1094 den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP auf
Drucksache 958 in der
ausschussfassung anzunehmen mir liegt
eine Vielzahl von Erklärung nach
§ 31 unserer Geschäftsordnung vor
entsprechend unserer Geschäftsordnung
neben mir diese Erklärung zu Protokoll
ich bitte nun diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
Dankeschön wer stimmt dagegen
Dankeschön wer enthält sich niemand der
Gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
tschuldigung
der Gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
Beratung
mit den Stimmen der Fraktionen der SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und der FDP gegen
die Stimmen der
cdu/csu-fraktion der afd-fraktion und
der Fraktion DIE LINKE angenommen bei
Enthaltung des Abgeordneten Matthias W
Burgwald
dritte Beratung und
Schlussabstimmung die Fraktionen der
cdu/csu und der AFD haben namentliche
Abstimmung verlangt die Abstimmung
erfolgt in der westlobby sie haben zur
Abgabe ihrer Stimme nach Eröffnung der
Abstimmung 20 Minuten Zeit bitte denken
Sie daran dass wir unmittelbar nach
Eröffnung der namentlichen Abstimmung
noch weitere Abstimmungen durchführen
werden diejenigen Abgeordneten hier im
Saal bitte ich somit noch einen Moment
zu bleiben
ich bitte die schriftführerinnen und
Schriftführer die vorgesehenen Plätze
einzunehmen
mir wird signalisiert dass das schon der
Fall ist
ich eröffne die namentliche
abschlussabstimmung über den
Gesetzentwurf auf Drucksache
die
abstimmungsurnen werden um 11 Uhr sechs
geschlossen
das bevorstehende Ende der namentlichen
Abstimmung wird Ihnen rechtzeitig
bekannt gegeben
Tagesordnungspunkt 21 B Abstimmung über
den von den Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis
90 die Grünen und FDP
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Verlängerung des sozialdienstleister
einsatzgesetzes und weitere Regelungen
der Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales
empfiehlt in seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache
1055 den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktionen
der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
auf Drucksache
959 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen und
die Fraktion DIE LINKE wer stimmt
dagegen
niemand wer enthält sich
danke darf ich erfahren wie die
cdu/csu-fraktion sich verhält
gut also wir wiederholen die
Veranstaltung und die Abstimmung und
stellen Protokoll sicher das Ergebnis
fest ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung es
handelt sich um die Verlängerung des
sozialdienstleister einsatzgesetzes und
weiterer Regelungen zustimmen wollen
nochmals um das Handzeichen
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen die
cdu/csu-fraktion und die Fraktion DIE
LINKE wer stimmt dagegen
niemand wer enthält sich die
afd-fraktion danke der Gesetzentwurf ist
damit in zweiter Beratung angenommen
dritte Beratung und Schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
danke wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
danke der Gesetzentwurf ist mit den
Stimmen der Koalitionsfraktionen der
cdu/csu-fraktion und der Fraktion DIE
LINKE bei Enthaltung der afd-fraktion
angenommen
Tagesordnungspunkt 21c
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses für
Gesundheit zu der Verordnung der
Bundesregierung zur Änderung der COBIT
19 Schutzmaßnahmen
Ausnahmeverordnung der Ausschuss
empfiehlt in seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache 1062 der Verordnung auf
Drucksache 952 zuzustimmen wer stimmt
für diese Beschlussempfehlung
die Koalitionsfraktionen und die
Fraktionen die Linke wer stimmt dagegen
die afd-fraktion wer enthält sich die
Fraktionen der cdu/csu die
Beschlussempfehlung ist damit angenommen
Tagesordnungspunkt 21 D Abstimmung über
die Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses
für Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend
zu dem Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
mit dem Titel
einkommensausfälle für junge Eltern beim
Elterngeld auffangen
coronabedingte elterngeldregelungen
Verlängern der Ausschuss empfiehlt in
seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache
1.063 den Antrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache
1007 abzulehnen
wer stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich die
Beschlussempfehlung ist mit den Stimmen
der koalitionsfraktion gegen die Stimmen
der Oppositionsfraktionen angenommen
Tagesordnungspunkt
21e
interfraktionell wird Überweisung der
Vorlage auf Drucksache 1014 an die in
der Tagesordnung aufgeführten Ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen gibt es weitere
überweisungsvorschläge das ist nicht der
Fall dann verfahren wir wie
vorgeschlagen
Zusatzpunkt 15 wir kommen zur Abstimmung
über die Beschlussempfehlung des
Ausschusses für Wahlprüfung Immunität
und Geschäftsordnung zur Änderung der
Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages hier Verlängerung der
Geltungsdauer der Regelung zur
besonderen Anwendung der
Geschäftsordnung aufgrund der
allgemeinen Beeinträchtigung durch
kurbit 19
§
126a der Geschäftsordnung des
Bundestages wer stimmt für die
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 1050
die
Koalitionsfraktionen und die Fraktion
DIE LINKE wer stimmt dagegen die
cdu/csu-fraktion und die afd-fraktion
wer enthält sich niemand die
Beschlussempfehlung ist angenommen
Zusatzpunkt 17
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses für
Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend zu
dem Antrag der Fraktion der AFD mit dem
Titel alle corona-maßnahmen für Kinder
sofort beenden das Kindeswohl bei allen
corona-maßnahmen Prüfen der Ausschuss
empfiehlt in seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache 1064 den Antrag der
Fraktion der AFD auf Drucksache 2019
abzulehnen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen danke wer
enthält sich die Beschlussempfehlung ist
gegen die Stimmen der afd-fraktion bei
Zustimmung aller übrigen Fraktionen des
Hauses angenommen
Zusatzpunkt 18
interfraktionell wird Überweisung der
Vorlage auf Drucksache 1005 an die in
der Tagesordnung aufgeführten Ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen gibt es weitere
überweisungsvorschläge das ist nicht der
Fall dann verfahren wir wie
vorgeschlagen
das Ergebnis der namentlichen
Schlussabstimmung über den Gesetzentwurf
wird ihnen erst nach dem
Tagesordnungspunkt 22 mitgeteilt im
Anschluss daran folgt die Abstimmung
über die
Entschließungsanträge ich bitte das bei
ihren weiteren Planungen für diesen Tag
zu berücksichtigen
ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte
22a und
22b Beratung der Anträge der Fraktionen
der cdu/csu mit den Titeln durch
technologieoffenheit die Transformation
der
Automobilindustrie beschleunigen und die
Klimaschutzziele erreichen und Tempo
machen bei Verkehrsprojekten weitere
beschleunigungspotenziale heben für die
Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von 68
Minuten beschlossen
ich bitte nun die Plätze einzunehmen
so ich bitte jetzt zügig die weitere
Verhandlungsbereitschaft hier
herzustellen
ich eröffne die Aussprache das Wort hat
der Kollege Dr Christoph Ploss für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Angriffskrieg von Putin
Russland auf die Ukraine der wirft auch
bei uns in Deutschland Fragen in
Hinblick auf die Mobilität auf viele
fragen sich gerade in diesen Tagen wie
kann Tanten wieder bezahlbar werden und
wie senken wir die hohen Spritkosten da
will ich zu Beginn der Debatte eines
einmal ganz klar in Richtung der
Ampelkoalition sagen sie sollten sofort
die Steuern senken sie sollten aufhören
sich in bürokratischen Debatten zur
verheddern sie sollen aufhören damit
dass eine Hand nicht weiß was die andere
in der Regierung tut wie zum Beispiel am
letzten Sonntag als Christian Lindner
mit dem Vorschlag eines
tankstellenrabatts kommt und ihm am
selben Tag der Robert Habeck
widerspricht das was wir jetzt wir
brauchen das ist Klarheit das ist nicht
Bürokratie sondern das sind
Steuersenkungen damit Tanken in
Deutschland wieder bezahlbar wird meine
Damen und Herren
und damit eng verbunden sind auch andere
Fragen die wir hier mit dem Antrag im
Deutschen Bundestag als cdu/csu-fraktion
beantworten wollen wie können wir
unabhängig von russischen Gas werden wie
können wir unabhängig von russischem Öl
werden auch im Mobilitätsbereich wie
können wir es schaffen CO2 im
Mobilitätssektor zu reduzieren
entscheidende Fragen auf die wir hier
Antworten finden müssen und wir haben
auch dazu eine klare Meinung wir sagen
wir wollen Technologie offen an dieses
große Thema an diese große
Herausforderung rangehen
und da muss ich sagen hätte ich mir
gerade von der FDP mehr Glaubwürdigkeit
in den vergangenen Wochen gewünscht im
Wahlkampf haben sie noch Stimmung
gemacht und gesagt bitte nicht nur rein
auf batterieantriebe sich konzentrieren
wir können die Klimaschutzziele nur
erreichen wir können die deutsche
Automobilindustrie nur stark machen wenn
wir technologieoffen rangehen das waren
die Aussagen im Wahlkampf kurz danach
kassiert Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing
genau das in einem Interview im
Tagesspiegel und es gibt
unterschiedliche Aussagen aus der
Ampelkoalition bis hin dazu dass gestern
ganz stolz von der Bundesregierung eine
Pressemitteilung herausgegeben wird dass
das Ende des Verbrennungsmotors
bevorsteht das ist genau das Gegenteil
dessen liebe Kolleginnen der FDP was sie
im Wahlkampf versprochen haben
und und ich möchte Ihnen deswegen eines
auch bei der Gelegenheit in Stammbuch
schreiben und hoffe dass sie deswegen
auch unseren Antrag heute unterstützen
werden es ist nicht die Frage setzen wir
auf batterieantriebe setzen wir auf
Wasserstoff setzen wir auf klimaneutrale
Kraftstoffe wie efuels setzen wir auf
Biokraftstoffe wir werden alle zur
Verfügung stehenden Werkzeuge alle zur
Verfügung stehenden Instrumente
benötigen damit wir die Klimaschutzziele
erreichen und damit die deutschen
Autobauer und damit die Zulieferer auch
in den nächsten Jahren stark sein können
und damit Arbeitsplätze in Deutschland
erhalten werden
und das ist verehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen deswegen nicht eine Frage des
entweder oder entweder Batterie oder
Wasserstoff entweder Batterie oder
e-fuits sondern es ist eine Frage des
sowohl als auch und daher kann ich nur
sein sie brauchen und wir müssen es
schaffen gleiche Rahmenbedingungen für
alle klimafreundlichen Technologien in
Deutschland zu gewährleisten alle müssen
die gleiche Ausgangslage haben alle
müssen die gleichen Chancen haben und
wir brauchen im besten Sinne des Wortes
einen Wettbewerb der klimafreundlichen
Technologien in Deutschland
und daher ist es auch falsch was sie in
den letzten Tagen erneut mehrfach zum
Ausdruck gebracht haben das Ende des
Verbrennungsmotors einzuläuten denn wir
werden selbst wenn wir alle E-Auto Ziele
erreichen wofür wir als cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr sind werden wir immer noch über 35
Millionen Verbrenner in den 2030er
Jahren auf deutschlandstraßen haben auch
die müssen klimaneutral werden wenn wir
die Klimaschutzziele erreichen wollen
wenn sie mit einem Unternehmen wie
Porsche sprechen dann sagen die Ihnen
genau das die sagen nicht setzt nur auf
Batterie oder setzt nur auf e-fuels
sondern ein Unternehmen wie Porsche sagt
wir brauchen beides wir brauchen gute
Rahmenbedingungen für batterieantriebe
und wir brauchen gute politische
Rahmenbedingungen auch für e-fuels und
deswegen
unterstützen Sie unseren Antrag setzen
Sie sich für technologieoffenheit ein
setzen sie sich für soziale
Marktwirtschaft ein setzen sie sich für
mehr Forschung in Batterie in
Wasserstoff in Klima neutrale
Kraftstoffe ein gehen sie weg von ihrer
Technologie das sage ich gerade im
Hinblick auf die FDP und kommen Sie
wieder auf einen klaren bürgerlichen
Pfad zurück herzlichen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
zu seiner ersten Rede im Deutschen
Bundestag hat nun der Kollege Jürgen
Berghahn für die SPD-Fraktion das Wort
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Beispiel der Maronen rahmente-brücke an
der A45 zeigt uns sehr deutlich dass wir
beim Thema planungsbeschleunigung Tempo
machen müssen aber die letzten Wochen
zeigen auch dass die Bundesregierung
genau dies tut
das Verkehrsministerium hat letzte Woche
das zukunftspaket leistungsfähige
autobrück Autobahnbrücke und vorgelegt
und mit dem darin enthaltenen neun
Punkteplan wirklich eine Zeitenwende
eingeleitet der Einsatz modernster
digitaler Technologien bessere
Kommunikation und Abstimmung zwischen
allen Beteiligten sowie eine
zukunftsgerichtete Planung sind nur
einige Aspekte die wir verbessern und
voranbringen werden
das klingt ziemlich abstrakt aber wir
haben einen sehr konkreten Fahrplan
ausgearbeitet und setzen diesen bei den
Planungen zur Ramme total Brücke um
womöglich laufen auch planungen Prozesse
Beteiligungsverfahren parallel
zueinander um die Planungsphase deutlich
zu verkürzen es ist wirklich interessant
dass jetzt ausgerechnet von der CDU
Tempo bei Verkehrsprojekten verlangt
wird
denn das Abgeordnete aus NRW weiß ich
natürlich genau das NRW seit inzwischen
fünf Jahren von der CDU regiert wird
ganz offensichtlich wurde bei der
Talbrücke damals von Verkehrsminister
Hendrik wüst nicht vorausschauend
geplant
da ist es jetzt einfach auf die
Bundesregierung zu zeigen und mehr
Einsatz zu verlangen
sie haben für die heutige Sitzung einen
Antrag eingereicht in dem einige gute
Maßnahmen sicher enthalten sind die
werden wir auch entsprechend
berücksichtigen aber bitte haben Sie
denn ihre Zeit vergessen wo es
csu-bundes Verkehrsminister waren und
die hätten diese Dinge auch schon längst
umsetzen können
insgesamt gesehen ist der Antrag ein
riesiges Sammelsurium altbekannter wenig
strategische Ansätze und wurde
offensichtlich nur gestellt um die
Koalition auf angebliche Versäumnisse
hinzuweisen die es ja aber nicht gibt
dieses Beispiel und auch das gesamte
Thema planungsbeschleunigung eignen sich
jedoch nicht für den Wahlkampf oder
Konfrontation keine Partei keine Partei
hat in der Vergangenheit alles richtig
gemacht sie können sich aber darauf
verlassen dass die SPD und die Koalition
alles dafür tun wird Prozesse so weit
wie möglich und sinnvoll zu
beschleunigen
bitte bedenken Sie auch dass das Thema
planungsbeschleunigungs uns alle
betrifft alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger
alle Wahlkreise Stadt Land vielleicht
auch die Baustelle vor ihrer eigenen
Haustür
dementsprechend wünsche ich mir dass wir
Probleme als gemeinsame Probleme
erkennen und die dann auch gemeinsam
gelöst werden können
natürlich müssen nicht nur Brücken
sondern auch Straßen Radwege Schienen
Wasserstraßen zügig modernisiert werden
und es muss nicht nur im Verkehrswegen
Wesen sondern auch im Bereichen Umwelt
Digitalisierung und Energie Tempo
gemacht werden
für die zentralen Vorhaben der
Bundesregierung geht es gar nicht anders
nur so können wir die können wir eine
digitalisierte Gesellschaft die
Klimaschutzziele und den Ausbau
erneuerbarer Energien erreichen
gerade die erneuerbaren Energien sind
derzeit in aller Munde der schlimme
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine zeigt uns
sehr deutlich dass wir zu lange auf
vertraute Mittel gesetzt und zu wenig
auf unsere Unabhängigkeit geachtet haben
dementsprechend sollten wir diesen
Weckruf alle äußerst ernst nehmen und
auch in diesem Bereich Planungen
deutlich beschleunigen
es geht nicht nur mehr um Nachhaltigkeit
sondern auch um die eigene Sicherheit
dem Wohlstand und damit die Zukunft
unseres Landes deshalb werden wir noch
vor Ostern erste gesetzliche Vorgaben
verabschieden und unsere
Energieversorgung auch für die Zukunft
zu sichern anschließend wird die
Koalition bis Herbst weitere gesetzliche
Maßnahmen zur planungsbeschleunigung und
Strukturanpassung verabschieden und
endgültig beschließen
viele Kollegen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sie sehen dass wir aus ganz
unterschiedlichen Gründen Tempo machen
müssen um zukunftsfähig zu sein und zu
bleiben um nachhaltiger zu werden
selbstverständlich auch um unserer
Verantwortung dem Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern gegenüber gerecht zu werden
vielen Dank
sie sehen ich bin auch bei der Rede im
Planungsziel gebrandet man könnte auch
sagen ich quatschen machen so wie das
die Kollektion und die Bundesregierung
machen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die afd-fraktion gebe ich doch getag
Spanien
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren das was hier
zugrunde liegt der ganzen Diskussion ist
die Verkehrswende das ist ein
politisches Projekt auf EU-Ebene und
ziel dieses Projektes ist es Autofahren
also Individualverkehr immer
unbezahlbarer und unattraktiver zu
machen und das passiert auf europäischer
Ebene mit der
flottenverbrauchsvorgabe der
Europäischen Union die den Antrieb von
Fahrzeugen mit Verbrennungsmotoren
perspektivisch unmöglich macht ob sie es
jetzt verbieten oder nicht es ist so die
verbrauchsvorgaben sind nicht zu
erfüllen jetzt gibt es zwei
Möglichkeiten die eine sprechen Sie hier
an das ist die Transformation der
Automobilindustrie hin zu
Elektromobilität das geht einher mit
einem kompetenzwechsel in der Industrie
hin von also kapitalverarbeitender
Industrie hin zur Elektrochemie und da
muss jeder wissen der sich damit
auskennt und die haben Sie
wahrscheinlich jetzt die Rückmeldung
gekriegt das geht in der Praxis
überhaupt nicht die mittelständische
Industrie die heute Metallteile
bearbeitet kann keine Zellen herstellen
das ist eine komplett infantile
Vorstellung das heißt es geht einher mit
massiven Arbeitsplatzverlusten die
Alternative dazu das ist im Grunde
genommen unser Programm das ist die
Anerkennung synthetischer Kraftstoffe
auf den Flottenverbrauch auf
europäischer Ebene das ist Politik der
AFD von Tag eins da brauchen Sie gar
keine Transformation der
Automobilindustrie
konkret zu ihrem Antrag jetzt also sie
fordern im ersten Schritt die
Transformation hin zu
einer Transformation der
Automobilindustrie und dann haben sie
unter Punkt 5 das abgeschrieben was wir
hier seit Tag eins fordern die
Anerkennung synthetischer Kraftstoffe
auf den Flottenverbrauch da freue ich
mich drüber dass sie das übernommen
haben die FDP hat ja auch schon
übernommen gehabt in Forderungen aber da
müssen sie auch konsequent sein es ist
nicht so dass man dann auch
technologische Vorgaben machen muss wie
hier die Plug-in-Hybride noch fordern
das ist totaler Unsinn und ganz ehrlich
ich hätte mich gefreut wenn Sie diesen
Antrag ernst gemeint hätten und hier
nicht sofort Abstimmung beantragt hätten
sondern wir das in den Ausschüssen
diskutiert hätten da hätten wir sehr
wohl eine gemeinsame Position finden
können das hier ist so wie er hier heute
abgestimmt wird ein schaufensterantrag
von ihnen um die Gemüter in den Ländern
zu beruhigen damit sie eben auch das
Gefühl haben die CDU interessiert sich
überhaupt für die Arbeitsplätze
Tatsache ist Tatsache ist es wird nicht
anders gehen wenn man die Arbeitsplätze
erhalten will wird es in diesem Land
nicht anders gehen als genau der
politiklinie die wir vertreten haben zu
folgen dass man die synthetischen
Kraftstoffe anerkennt so ich komme jetzt
noch zu ihrem zweiten Antrag das ist ja
da betrifft es mit Recht die komplett
verfehlte Infrastrukturpolitik der
letzten Jahre gerade was das Thema
Straßenbau angeht sie machen eine
Generalabrechnung sie machen eine
Generalabrechnung und das Ganze ist
deshalb ein Treppenwitz weil genau diese
Politik die sie hier kritisieren die
haben sie die letzten 12 Jahre elementar
mitgestaltet sie können auch nicht den
Menschen erzählen dass sie jetzt alles
anders machen wollen wo sie nichts mehr
zu sagen haben das ist doch ein Witz und
das wissen Sie ja auch das heißt
tatsächlich ist es aber so dass in ihrem
Ansatz speziell in dem zweiten Antrag
den Sie hier gestellt haben da finden
wir sehr viele konstruktive Elemente die
übrigens auch Politik und die Anträge
der AFD widerspiegeln und deshalb können
wir Ihnen hier sagen in diesem zweiten
Antrag zu Beschleunigung der
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen und der
Veränderung der Gesetzgebung dem stimmen
wir vollumfänglich zu dass es genau das
was wir immer gefordert haben
und zu dem ersten Antrag wie gesagt wenn
wir selbst über den ganzen ideologischen
Ballast den sie da eingebaut haben
befreit bleibt dieser Antrag in sich
unlogisch wir wollen keine
Transformation der Automobilindustrie
wir wollen die Arbeitsplätze erhalten
und deshalb können wir ihrem Antrag
selbstverständlich so nicht zustimmen
ich hätte mich gefreut wir hätten in dem
Ausschuss beraten wir hätten ihn
bestimmt so geändert gekriegt dass wir
tatsächlich hier auch zugestimmt hätten
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
ich komme zunächst noch mal zurück zu
Tagesordnungspunkt
21a die Zeit für die namentliche
Abstimmung ist gleich vorbei und ich
frage ist denn noch ein Mitglied des
Hauses anwesend dass seine Stimme nicht
abgegeben hat
tatsächlich
fix die Waldfee
gut dann
[Musik]
warten wir noch einen Redebeitrag lang
und der kommt von Nikis Larvik für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und das ist ihre
erste Rede auf die wir uns sehr freuen
sehr geehrte Abgeordnete sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin lieber Herr Ploss ja 16
Jahre haben sie regiert cdu/csu 12 Jahre
lang davon das Verkehrsministerium und
was ist ihre Bilanz sie haben Millionen
Menschen in Deutschland abhängig gemacht
vom Auto weil sie die alternativen
vernachlässigt haben schienen und
öpnv-ausbau vollkommen vergessen
Dienstwagen Fett gefördert aber Menschen
in Bus Bahn und Rad im Regen stehen
gelassen dafür zahlen gerade Millionen
Menschen hierzulande einen hohen Preis
an der Zapfsäule und die Ölmilliarden
die fließen dann auch noch in
putinskriegskasse weil wir ein Drittel
unseres Rohöls aus Russland beziehen so
kann darf und wird es nicht weitergehen
sie predigen hier heute wieder das
Märchen von der technologieoffenheit
dabei haben wir alles was wir brauchen
schon heute die E-Autos kommen ob sie
wollen oder nicht eine Stärkung von
Schiene Bus und Rad ist fürs Klima
unverzichtbar und das deutsche
Straßennetz retten wir indem wir endlich
einen Fokus auf die Sanierung legen
statt uns in überdimensionierten
Neubauten fest zu beißen und hier komme
ich nämlich zu ihrem zweiten Antrag man
muss sich schon sehr wundern dass
cdu/csu heute den schlechten Zustand
unserer Infrastruktur beklagen obwohl
sie genau 16 Jahre dafür Zeit gehabt
hätten dass sie sich heute hier
hinstellen und als Retter der deutschen
Verkehrsinfrastruktur darstellen ist
schon ziemlich peinlich was haben Sie
stattdessen gemacht vor allem viele
ungelöste Baustellen hinterlassen
tausende Brücken hierzulande sind
dringend sanierungsbedürft bekannt ist
das nicht erst seit gestern nicht erst
seit der rammelte Talbrücke und der
Sperrung der A45 bekannt ist das seit
vielen Jahren
und jetzt CSU-Kollege andreas Scheuer
hat das Problem
ignoriert ihr CDU-Kollege aus NRW
Ministerpräsident Hendrik wüst jahrelang
Verkehrsminister in NRW hat das Problem
ignoriert wir wissen aus dem NRW-Landtag
das Straßen NRW unter der Führung von
Herrn wüst die Instandhaltung der
rammeldetalbrücke 2017
herunterstufte obwohl bekannt war wie
gefährlich das sein könnte
herunterstufte zugunsten von hunderten
Neubauprojekten und damit die nötige
Sanierung vertagte jahrelang haben
cdu/csu die Verkehrsplanung zugunsten
Hunderter Neubau und
Erweiterungsprojekte aufgebläht
1300 fernstraßenprojekte 850 Kilometer
neue Autobahn nur haben sie dabei
vergessen tausende Brücken in
Deutschland zu sanieren das Recht sich
jetzt ich weiß wovon ich rede ich komme
aus Leverkusen die Leverkusener
Rheinbrücke kummerode dass sie jetzt neu
gebaut wird und zwar als Doppelbrücke
mit 12 Fahrspuren auch hier grüßt der
Erweiterungsbau in zwölf Fahrspuren über
den Rhein das nenne ich mal eine richtig
fette riesen Autobahn schade nur dass es
da auch noch eine andere Krise gibt die
Klimakrise und die ukraine-krise beides
fliegt uns jetzt im Verkehrssektor um
die Ohren dank 16 Jahren völlig
verfehlter Verkehrspolitik von ihnen wir
werden es anders machen vielen Dank
jetzt komme ich noch mal zurück halt ich
muss diese Lobby Dings drücken ich komme
nochmal zurück zu Tagesordnungspunkt 21a
und Frage erneut ist noch ein Mitglied
des Hauses anwesend dass seine
Stimmkarte nicht abgeben konnte das ist
jetzt nicht mehr der Fall dann schließe
ich die Abstimmung und bitte die
Schriftführerin und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu beginnen das Ergebnis
wird ihnen erst nach Tagesordnungspunkt
22 bekannt gegeben
und ich komme zurück zu unserer Debatte
und gebe das Wort dem Kollegen Thomas
Lutze für die Linke
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
vor allen Dingen von der Unionsfraktion
ich möchte zum Thema Transformation
schwerpunktmäßig meine vier Minuten
Redezeit nutzen da ich das für ein sehr
wichtiges Thema alte vor allen Dingen
auch aus Sicht der ArbeitnehmerInnen
Arbeitnehmer
es geht hier um die Zukunft der
Automobilindustrie das ist von meinen
Vorrednerinnen und vorrätern richtig
festgehalten worden und es geht darum
wie gehen wir damit um das 100.000
Arbeitsplätze bundesweit zu Disposition
stehen und dass das Arbeitsplätze sind
die in der Regel Tarif gebunden und dank
IG Metall überdurchschnittlich bezahlt
werden
der Antrag der Union
stehen auch viele richtige Sachen drin
ist aber hochinteressant
nämlich genau dieses Thema der
Arbeitsplätze sie haben dann Ranking sie
machen 18 Punkte und machen da quasi in
Ranking mit auf mit der Nummerierung und
das Thema Arbeitsplätze ist sage und
schreibe top 17 also da muss für meine
Begriffe mal allen Beteiligten klar
werden welchen Stellenwert die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in
diesem Betrieb bei Ihnen bei der Union
haben nämlich so gut wie gar keine das
geht überhaupt nicht
ich selber ich lebe seit Jahrzehnten
seit drei Jahrzehnten im Saarland das
ist mein neues Zuhause seit vielen
Jahren dort gibt es mehrere zehntausend
Arbeitsplätze in dem Bereich das ist
fort in Saarlouis ZF in Saarbrücken
Busch oder Schäffler in Homburg um die
großen zu nennen aber es gibt auch viele
mittelständische Unternehmen und vor
allem was oft vergessen wird auch viele
Serviceunternehmen die davon abhängig
sind von der jetzigen Automobilindustrie
man muss den Wählerinnen und Wählern die
in genau neuen Tagen im Saarland
zugrunde gerufen werden dann schon mal
genau sagen welche Politik hier im
Deutschen Bundestag die Union verfolgt
schließlich stellen Sie dann noch den
Ministerpräsidenten ich hoffe dass ich
das ändert
zweitens
wir müssen auch die Automobilkonzerne
mal genau unter die Lupe nehmen und
jetzt gehört die Linke noch nicht
unbedingt dazu die da zum fendtop der
Automobilkonzerne gehört aber ich
versuche es mal es gibt nämlich außer
der angesprochenen Ford Entschuldigung
außerdem angesprochenen Porsche
überhaupt kein Automobilkonzern mehr der
überhaupt irgendwas in Richtung
Verbrenner noch macht davon
technologieoffenheit zu reden tut mir
leid den Antrag hätten sie vielleicht in
der 18 Wahlperiode stellen können aber
Ihnen hier und heute zu stellen ist
einfach völlig nicht mehr der Zeit
angemessen das ist Schnee von gestern es
gibt Kollegen möchten Sie eine
zwischenfragebemerkung aus der AFD
zulassen
also wir haben in den Automobilkonzernen
seit langem
eine Politik Firmenpolitik die sich
darauf eingestellt hat dass ich dort was
ändert es gibt gerade vor rund einer
Woche hat vor einer der großen
Hersteller mit zwei Standorten in
Saarlouis und Köln die erklärt haben
2030 ist Schluss mit dem Verbrenner
sollen wir jetzt hier Gesetze
beschließen oder Anträge beschließen die
genau das Gegenteil machen ich glaube
das ist auch der falsche Weg
technologieoffenheit ist schnell von
gestern das ist abgehakt wichtig ist mit
der dritte Punkt das Thema
Transformation und das wird oft
missverstanden als ein Thema weg vom
Verbrenner hin zum Batterieantrieb wir
brauchen eine Industrie ein ein Wandel
und das wird in der Transformation
zumindest was die Gewerkschaften was
viele Verbände kann man und so weiter
machen da geht es um einen Wandel der
Automobilproduktion zu anderen
Industrieprodukten zur alternativen zum
Automobil
da gibt es natürlich noch keine Lösung
kein Grundrezept aber wir brauchen
Produktion Industrieproduktion zum
Beispiel Fahrräder Solarzellen
Straßenbahn Busse die Liste lässt sich
x-beliebig verlängern es geht darum dass
die Arbeitsplätze erhalten werden die
gut bezahlte und überdurchschnittlich
gut bezahlte Arbeitsplätze erhalten
werden dass den Menschen die dort
arbeiten ist am Ende egal ob sie Autos
produzieren oder etwas anderes
produzieren es geht darum dass man den
Wandel schafft und das ist
Transformation und nicht nur der bloße
Umgang von zur Automobil und es bleibt
mein letzter Bemerkung dazu es bleibt
auch ein verkehrspolitisches Ziel im
Mittelpunkt wir brauchen eine
Verkehrspolitik wo niemand mehr sagen
kann oder sagen muss sie oder er sei auf
ein Automobil angewiesen es muss eine
Politik her wo die Alternativen zum
autokonsequent gefördert werden das
heißt nicht dass man das Autofahren
verbietet der Rest von vielleicht 15
oder 20 Millionen Autos die übrig
bleiben die können von mir aus
batterieelektrisch sein aber Mobilität
muss schwerpunktmäßig über den
öffentlichen Personennahverkehr oder den
öffentlichen Verkehr erfolgen und dann
haben wir auch eine Transformation
geschafft die man genau so bezeichnen
kann vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die Bundesregierung spricht jetzt zu
uns der Parlamentarische Staatssekretär
Oliver Luxus
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Verkehrssektor steht vor großen
Herausforderungen die wir heute
debattieren erlauben Sie mir bei
eingangs zur aktuellen Krise und in der
Ukraine und das was das auch für unseren
Verkehrsbereich bedeutet einige Worte zu
sagen
Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing ist auf
Einladung seines polnischen Amtskollegen
sofort an die Grenze gefahren mit den
Amtskollegen mit der
u-verkehrskommissarin sich ausgetauscht
und er hat schnell und pragmatisch
gehandelt mein Dank geht an alle im Haus
im Bag vor allem aber auch an die
Deutsche Bahn die dafür sorgt dass wir
mit mit Sonderzügen die Menschen schnell
in Sicherheit bringen dass DB Cargo eine
schienenbrücke aufgebaut hat um die
dringend benötigten Hilfsgüter an die
Grenzen zu bringen das ist schnelle
unbürokratische Hilfe auch von den
vielen Busunternehmen die Güter
hinfahren Menschen zu uns in Sicherheit
bringen das ist eine großartige Leistung
auf die
natürlich müssen wir auch unsere Themen
hier angehen und Deutschland muss in der
Tat vor allem schneller planen
Genehmigung und bauen wenn wir heute
darüber reden ein Stück Schiene in
Betrieb zu nehmen kann das bis zu 20
Jahre dauern das kann und darf so nicht
bleiben und deswegen haben wir als
erstes auch und das ist kein einfaches
Thema wir haben es aber angegangen weil
es notwendig ist das Thema brückenbilanz
und brückengipfel auf die Tagesordnung
gesetzt
wir haben einen neuen Fokus wir haben
alle Brücke nachberechnet ein Fokus auf
die Traglast also die Frage nicht nur
von außen die Brücke zu bewerten sondern
eben genau reinzuschauen neu zu
berechnen mit den Verkehrsströmen und
deswegen haben wir uns auch auf dem
brückengipfel zusammen mit der
Bauwirtschaft mit den Umweltverbänden
mit den vielen Genehmigungsbehörden
dafür gesorgt und das ist unser Ziel
dass wir in unserem Land einen
infrastrukturkonsens hinbekommen neuen
Maßnahmen damit wir schneller den großen
investitionsschau abbauen den wir
vorgefunden haben
wir erhöhen die Mittel im Haushalt an
stärkerer Fokus auf den Halt bis 26 soll
es hier eine Milliarde Euro mehr geben
wir haben einen Fokus auf das Kernnetz
wir priorisieren weil Brücken die
Lebensadern unserer Wirtschaft sind
deswegen muss das hier funktionieren der
Sanierungsstau wird Schritt für Schritt
abgearbeitet liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das gilt für alle
Verkehrsträger Schienenwege Wasserstraße
Radwege digitale Infrastruktur die
gigabit-strategie wurde vorgestellt wir
haben acht Modellprojekte aus denen wir
Schlussfolgerungen ziehen wollen vor
allem bim also vernetzt planen bauen und
bewirtschaften und was ganz wichtig ist
das sehen wir ja gerade jetzt bei der
A45 dass wir die Verfahren ändern wir
haben setzen hier auf die funktionale
Ausschreibung auf den Dialog und die
frühe Einbeziehung aller Betroffenen
deswegen haben wir einen
Bürgerbeauftragten eingesetzt um eben
die Konflikte ganz früh am Anfang zu
lösen
sobald wir eben nicht in große
Rechtsstreitigkeiten reinbekommen das
ist ein neuer Ansatz eine Politik wo wir
zuhören alle einbinden damit wir
schneller vorankommen bei uns im Land
wir müssen Mobilität sicher bezahlbar
und nachhaltig gestalten das ist Ziel
der Bundesregierung das Erreichen der
Klimaziele aber auch der Vision Zero
deswegen ist es notwendig jetzt zu
handeln deswegen müssen wir schauen
welche Instrumente haben wir die jetzt
sofort wirken und das ist natürlich zum
einen die E-Mobilität und da ist es nun
mal so dass das was wir vorgefunden
haben bei der Ladeinfrastruktur nicht
ausreicht deswegen müssen wir die sehr
sehr viel schneller aufbauen wir müssen
jetzt auf das setzen was jetzt verfügbar
ist das ist ein ganz wichtiger Ansatz
unserer Regierung
und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Kolbenmotor der kann eben alles vom
Zweirad bis zum Flugzeug und das wird in
Zukunft so nicht gehen es gibt nicht
eine Technologie Lösung die alles kann
sondern verschiedene Anwendungen
deswegen fördert unser Haus auch
technologieoffen alternative Kraftstoffe
wasserstoffbatterie getriebene
E-Mobilität im Bereich der Nutzfahrzeuge
1,6 Milliarden Euro und das ist eben der
Unterschied wir machen
technologieoffene Klimaschutzpolitik und
wir benutzen nicht das Wort
technologieoffenheit und beim
Klimaschutz nicht zu tun das war glaube
ich in der Vergangenheit der Fall
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
werden Kollegen es gibt eine den
Wirtschaft Zwischenfrage aus der AFD
möchten Sie den zulassen bitteschön na
gut ich frage immer nur einmal ne Rede
ja vielen Dank Herr luxic dass sie
Zwischenfrage zulassen es geht noch mal
ganz konkret um ihre Politik gegenüber
synthetischen Kraftstoffen und
Biokraftstoffen sie haben gerade gesagt
sie fördern die sie wissen ganz genau
dass der synthetische Kraftstoff und
damit auch der komplette
Verbrennungsmotor an den
flottenverbrauchsvorgaben tatsächlich in
der EU hängt mit den aktuellen
flottenverbrauchsvorgaben und der nicht
Anerkennung von synthetischen und
Biokraftstoffen ist gerade eben eine
Zukunft des Verbrennungsmotors nicht
möglich darf ich ihre Rede jetzt so
verstehen wenn sie synthetische
Kraftstoffe fordern dass sie sich genau
dafür einsetzen dass diese Kraftstoffe
auf die flottenverbräuche der
Autohersteller anerkannt werden oder
habe ich das falsch verstanden
sehr geehrter Kollege sie wissen dass
wir im Haus bei uns das fördern wir
haben das eine Reihe an Förderprogramm
es gibt natürlich auch weitere
Anreizmechanismen die gelten zum
Beispiel die red2 und 3ditive und klar
ist und das ist die Position der
gemeinsame Position der Bundesregierung
dass wir dafür sorgen dass auch ab 2035
Verbrennungsmotoren zugelassen werden
können oder die Fahrzeuge mit
Verbrennungsmotoren wenn diese
nachweislich mit e-fuels betankt werden
also insofern ist für uns völlig klar
wir machen
technologieoffenen Klimaschutz und dazu
gehört auch aber eben nicht nur
alternative Kraftstoffe das ist die
Position der Bundesregierung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
müssen wie gesagt breit fördern es wird
ein Klimaschutz Sofortprogramm geben
technologieoffenheit ist wichtig aber
das hat man ja eben auch noch mal
gemerkt es ist ein sowohl als auch und
weil das ja eben auch in der Debatte
vorgekommen ist also ein weder noch ist
nicht die Lösung deswegen können wir
nicht alles was in den letzten 12 Jahren
sich aufgestaut hat in 100 Tagen lösen
wir sind aber mit Hochdruck dran und
freue mich auf die weitere Debatte
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
der Kollege Felix Schreiner hat das Wort
für die cdu/csu-fraktion
ja frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
eine ohne eine gut ausgebaute
Infrastruktur werden wir den Wohlstand
in unserem Land und übrigens auch
keinerlei Klimaschutzziele erreichen und
deshalb müssen wir weitere
planungspotenziale in diesem Land heben
und mit diesem
Antrag den wir heute mit einbringen
warten wir nicht lange ab wir warten
nicht ab bis irgendwelche Gipfel und
Arbeitsgruppen getagt haben sondern wir
setzen nahtlos daran fort dass wir vier
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetze in der
letzten Legislatur auf den Weg gebracht
haben übrigens gemeinsam mit der SPD
sehr geehrter Kollege das hätte ihnen
heute nicht geschadet das zu erwähnen es
ist nämlich ein gemeinsamer Erfolg
vielleicht ist das das Problem der SPD
gerade in diesen Tagen sie freuen sich
zu wenig über das was sie eigentlich
auch mal erreicht haben ich wollte sie
an dieser Stelle einfach noch mal in
Erinnerung rufen
und mit 33 Punkten in unserem Antrag zur
planungsbeschleunigung haben wir eine
klare Erwartungshaltung an die
Bundesregierung und setzen die
Erwartungshaltung an die Bundesregierung
dass wir den Erhalt und den Ausbau der
Infrastruktur beschleunigen dass wir
aber für die Menschen dem individuellen
Mobilitätsbedürfnis auch gerecht werden
und es ist ja schön wenn heute die einen
die Kollegin von den Grünen und auch von
der SPD und von der linke sowieso wir
dann gehört haben es braucht kein Auto
mehr und so weiter meine Damen und
Herren 60 Prozent der Bevölkerung lebt
in ländlichen Raum und wer nicht wer
nicht zulässt das ist auch in Zukunft
noch Straßenbau in diesem Land gibt der
verkennt die Wirklichkeit wir haben da
einen anderen Weg
und zur Wahrheit gehört doch es sind die
Projekte vor Ort die Frust machen viele
Projekte in den Gemeinden die für
Politikverdrossenheit symbolisch stehen
weil über Jahrzehnte hinweg geplant wird
und eben nicht gebaut werden konnte dass
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger uns allen
Abgeordneten aus den Wahlkreisen sagen
kann das eigentlich sein dass man 50
Jahre für ein Straßenbauprojekt für eine
Ortsumfahrung braucht das geht doch
allen zu lang und wenn wir uns der einig
sind da muss man auch mal klar benennen
woran es liegt Herr Kollege eine
Zwischenfrage aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
möchten Sie die gerne zulassen
und Herr Lutze sie können ja jetzt die
Maske abnehmen und ansonsten wäre es gut
über die Nase
ja lieber Kollege Schreiner sie haben
gerade das sinngemäß behauptet dass wir
irgendwie das Auto ab in usw würden Sie
bitte zur Kenntnis nehmen dass ich in
meiner vorherigen rede gerade gesagt
habe dass ich mich qualitative
Unterschied das niemand mehr drauf
angewiesen sein muss ein Auto zu fahren
das impliziert diese Aussage das ist
sehr wohl noch fahren darf also es will
ja niemand irgendwas verbieten es geht
darum dass es auch bei mir im Saarland
ganz viele Menschen gibt die Moment
vollkommen nachvollziehbar sagen sie
haben keine andere Möglichkeit als mit
dem Auto von A nach B zu kommen diesen
Zustand müssen wir gewinnen das hat
nichts damit zu tun wenn wir diesen
Missstand aufheben wollen dass wir das
Autofahren verbieten wollen das ist
völliger Unsinn es tut mir leid dann ist
es okay wenn Sie das nochmal gerade
stellen wir hatten es anders verstanden
weil ich sage Ihnen ganz offen sie
natürlich immer wieder und auch ein
Ausschüssen klipp und klar zum Ausdruck
bringen dass sie die Mobilität der
Menschen auch vorschreiben wollen und
ich sage Ihnen ich bin schon der Meinung
ich bin ein freiheitsliebender Mensch
jeder soll dazu bewegen wie er will aber
derjenige der im ländlichen Raum auf
sein Auto angewiesen ist sollte es auch
in Zukunft fahren können weil das geht
auch mit sozialer Teilhabe einher und
meinen wenn ich meine Rede fortsetzen
darf ich möchte an die Bundesregierung
sagen ich habe ja manchmal sogar Mitleid
auch mit Herrn Wissing und Herr Luksic
und der Staatssekretär teurer war zum
Beispiel neulich bei mir im Wahlkreis am
Hochrhein wir haben dort die 98 besucht
das war ein guter Termin er hat sich den
Bürgern gestellt wir haben Einigkeit
wird aber was ich da passiert was ist
dann passiert in den nächsten Tagen
Winnie Hermann aus Baden-Württemberg
schaltet sich zu Wort vom freien vom
Schreibtisch und erklärt das Ende der
hochrhein-autobahn A98 sagt alle
Planungen von Bundesverkehrswegeplan in
Baden-Württemberg kommen auf den
Prüfstand wir wollen keine Straßen mehr
bauen ihr meine Damen und Herren wir
müssen es doch mal beim Namen nennen
überall wo man mal ein Stück weit
vorankommen will sind die Grünen vor Ort
dies wieder torpedieren und wir haben es
auch heute in der Rede gehört
und deshalb ist es auch eine
Aufforderung von der Unionsfraktion an
die Bundesregierung sie haben im
Koalitionsvertrag reingeschrieben dass
sie den Bundesverkehrswegeplan in Gänze
mit dem Projekten überprüfen wollen in
Wahrheit wissen wir dass sie sich in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen natürlich auch
speziell von der grünen Seite da viel
haben anhören lassen müssen aber wir
bitten Sie wirklich machen sie das nicht
gehen sie da den Grünen nicht auf den
Leim eine Überprüfung des
bundesverkehrswegeplanen führt zu allem
zu eines nämlich nicht zur
planungsbeschleunigung in Deutschland
sondern dass viele viele Projekte hinten
runterfallen und das ist noch alles
länger geht sie haben uns an der Seite
wenn es darum geben und Herren wir haben
heute einen Antrag eingebracht wo wir
natürlich als Parlament das Instrument
der planungsgenehmigung mehr nutzen
möchten wir wollen rechtsverbindliche
Standards bei den Genehmigungsverfahren
setzen wir können das nationale
Naturschutzrecht auf die Vorhaben des
Unionsrechts begrenzen wir können die
Chancen der Digitalisierung nutzen wir
können eine Stichtagsregelung ein wir
können ein Bonus malus-regel für die
Bauverträge verbindlich prüfen das sind
alles Beispiele was man machen kann aber
zeigen sie liebe Regierungsfraktionen
dass sie wollen stimmen Sie unseren
Antrag heute zu es ist eine Fortsetzung
von vier Gesetzen die wir in der letzten
Legislaturperiode mit den
Sozialdemokraten auf den Weg gebracht
haben weil es uns ernst ist bei der
planungsbeschleunigung in Deutschland
[Applaus]
ich erkläre es noch mal kurz unser
Management hier weil die Besetzung im
Saal ja auch wechselt wir lassen in
dieser Woche pro Redebeitrag eine Frage
zwischen Frage oder die Frage danach zu
und dann keine mehr wenn jemand direkt
und persönlich angesprochen wird dann
kann eine Kurzintervention danach
erfolgen das könnte jetzt auch sein wenn
eine Fraktion insgesamt angesprochen
wird dass eine Kurzintervention erfolgt
habe ich aber jetzt keine Anmeldung dazu
allerdings ist es ja auch so dass nach
noch ein Redebeitrag durch die Grünen
fahren jetzt ja alles klar das ist dann
verstanden vielen Dank dann
gebe ich jetzt das Wort der Kollegin
Isabel
habe ich es falsch gesagt
ich muss dir nicht selbst noch mal
aufschreiben damit ich meine
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Kollegen
der CDU CSU ich muss schon sagen ihre
Reden heute hier fallen deutlich hinter
ihren Anträgen zurück und triefen nur so
vor Ideologie und ich will an der Stelle
auch den Grünen anbieten dass wir auch
in Baden-Württemberg über neue
Mehrheiten reden können wenn sie ihren
neuen Koalitionspartner brauchen
wir müssen doch zur Kenntnis nehmen dass
das Umweltbundesamt diese Woche auch
noch mal festgestellt hat dass der
Verkehrssektor seiner sektorziele bei
der CO2-Einsparung nicht erreicht hat
und auch wenn wir uns die
Kraftstoffpreise anschauen müssen Sie
uns eigentlich noch mehr ermutigen den
Weg für mehr Klimaschutz im Verkehr
entschlossen voranzubringen das ist
klimapolitisch richtig das ist
sicherheitspolitisch notwendig aber es
ist auch ökonomisch sinnvoll vorgestern
kam die Nachricht dass Elektroautofahrer
bis zu 70 Prozent günstiger unterwegs
sind aktuell als die die
Verbrennungsmotor fahren man könnte fast
meinen die Mineralölkonzerne Treiben mit
ihrer Abzocke an der Tankstelle ihre
eigene Bedeutungslosigkeit voran
ich würde mich auch freuen wenn Sie Ihre
auch durchaus sinnvollen Vorschläge für
mehr Klimaschutz im Verkehr an ihrem
Ministerpräsidenten im Saarland
Entschuldigung noch Ministerpräsidenten
im Saarland auch mal schicken würden
damit er sich damit mag gezielt
auseinandersetzen kann wie man
Transformation vor Ort umsetzen kann zum
Beispiel ladesäuleinfrastruktur ausbauen
statt peinliche Videos an der Tankstelle
zu drehen das hilft nämlich niemanden
und wenn Sie schon mal dabei sind
wenn Sie schon mal dabei sind schicken
Sie doch das Papier auch an Herrn Söder
in CC damit er aufhört beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien auf der Bremse zu
stellen denn wenn wir
strombasierte Kraftstoffe ist oder
Elektroautos wollen egal welche
Technologie alles braucht Strom und zwar
sehr viel davon und davon gibt es in
Süddeutschland eben nicht sehr viel und
besonders nicht erneuerbaren
sie fordern technologieoffenheit aber
die Autoindustrie hat sich doch
entschieden und fast alle Autokonzerne
setzen vorrangig auf E-Mobilität für die
nächsten zehn Jahre wir Kollegen Herr
Spaniel meldet sich wieder und möchte
bei Ihnen eine zwischen
nein
ja dazu komme ich jetzt sie
fordertechnologieoffenheit aber die
Autoindustrie hat sich entschieden und
wir als eine gute Ampelkoalition
unterstützen die Autoindustrie auf ihrem
Weg zur Immobilität indem wir die
Infrastruktur dafür bereitstellen das
nennt sich dann gute Industriepolitik
Infrastruktur schaffen
Infrastruktur schaffen die Innovation
fördert ziel ist es 15 Millionen
vollelektrische PKW bis 2030 und dafür
braucht es da haben Sie Recht in ihrem
Antrag
Halbleiterproduktion und
batteriezellenproduktion und deshalb ist
es besonders schön dass gerade diese
Woche zwei große Standortentscheidungen
angekündigt wurden einmal in Magdeburg
werden große Kapazitäten für
Halbleiterproduktion aufgebaut und in
Schleswig-Holstein eine gigafactory für
batteriezellenproduktion und Recycling
und man muss sich aber vor Augen führen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus
Süddeutschland dass diese
Standortentscheidungen in
Norddeutschland unter anderem begründet
wurden weil dort die Verfügbarkeit für
erneuerbare Energien vorhanden ist und
das führt uns noch mal ganz klar vor
Augen die Trägheit beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien in Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg wird zu einem echten
Standort Nachteil in Zukunft werden
also die Industrie hat erkannt
elektromobilität ist unschlagbar
effizient immer mehr Verbraucher fassen
auch Vertrauen in diese Technologie was
die langen Wartezeiten auch bei
Elektroautos zeigen der Hochlauf wird
exponentiell laufen wie beim Smartphone
und wir als Koalition unterstützen das
weil wir die Unabhängigkeit von
ölbasierten Sprit langfristig auch der
beste Weg ist um sicherzustellen dass
Mobilität bezahlbar bleibt vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Erik Holm hat jetzt das Wort für die
afd-fraktion
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Bürger liebe Kollegen es ist ja
wirklich schön anzusehen wie die Union
jetzt eine Position nach der anderen
räumt sie fordern jetzt ja sie fordern
jetzt in Teilen genau das Gegenteil von
dem was sie in 16 Jahren Regierung
vermurkst haben das ist ziemlich klar
sie schreiben jetzt in ihrem Antrag zur
Automobilindustrie der Verbrennungsmotor
wird teils vorschnell generell als
Klimasünder dargestellt die
Elektromobilität wird hingegen als
Königsweg beschrieben diese Kritik ist
vollkommen richtig die teilen wir wir
predigen das sogar schon seit Jahren
aber es hat sie in der Regierung nicht
die Bohne interessiert es war nämlich
ihre Politik unter Wirtschaftsminister
Altmaier Klammer auf cdu-klammer zu die
dazu geführt hat dass unsere
Autoindustrie den Bach runtergeht sie
können hier also nicht den Unschuld
Knaben lieben sie haben unter Merkel
jahrelang
und allein auf E-Autos gesetzt in der
Corona lockdown-krise haben sie massive
Kaufprämien ausgerufen nicht für moderne
Verbrenner nur nur für Stromer und das
hat überhaupt nichts mit
technologieoffenheit zu tun von der Sie
hier im Antrag sprechen und ich habe
noch gar nicht davon gesprochen wo
eigentlich der Strom für die Stromer
herkommen soll und diese künstliche
Bevorzugung der batterieautos stimmt sie
in Gang gesetzt haben die schadet
unserem Standort Deutschland
und wir sehen es doch die Produktion
sinkt stärker als in anderen
Industriebereichen die Beschäftigung
sinkt besonders bei den Zulieferern der
Rutsch in Richtung Ausland hat längst
begonnen und davor haben wir von Anfang
an gewahrt dass es ihr Werk
und wer freut sich eigentlich über die
riesigen Subvention ist jetzt gibt das
sind ausgerechnet die wenigen die sich
die besonders teuren E-Autos leisten
können so freuen sich die tesla-fahrer
dass ihre Neuwagen nach sechs Monaten
Richtung Dänemark verkaufen können und
dann sogar noch mehr als die Neupreis
erzielen sie machen noch einen Gewinn
dabei wenn das erstmal bekannt wird wird
es jeder tun ich freue mich schon drauf
das wird wirklich spannend und das zeigt
aber den ganzen
er beliebtes die sie betreiben ich finde
das Geld könnten wir wirklich sinnvoller
ausgeben schauen sich die Preise der
Tankstelle an
wer soll das denn noch bezahlen die
Milliarden Euro die die Bundesregierung
für diesen ganzen Prämien Klimbim
ausgegeben hat die hätten jetzt dabei
helfen können zum Beispiel die
Mehrwertsteuer an der Tanke temporär zu
senken und eine solche Erleichterung
brauchen die Bürger jetzt wirklich
dringend
Liebe Union sie fordern in ihrem Antrag
auch das unterschreibe ich sofort kein
unwiderrufliches Enddatum für die
Verbrennungsmotor festzulegen ja aber
lassen Sie mich auch hier ihrem
Gedächtnis mal auf die Sprünge helfen es
war ihr Parteifreund Söder der getrieben
von schwarz-grünen regierungsträumen die
Verbrennungsmotor bis 2035 beerdigen
wollte merken Sie was rindende
Kartoffeln ruht oder Kartoffeln man kann
ihnen nichts mehr glauben sie haben ihre
Glaubwürdigkeit längst verspielt
zusammengefasst es stehen durchaus
sinnvolle Punkte in ihrem Antrag aber
sie können den großen Widerspruch darin
nicht auflösen im Gegenteil er wird hier
richtig deutlich wollen sie nun
technologieoffenheit oder wollen Sie die
Transformation beschleunigen beides
zusammen passt nicht das ist wie ein
bisschen schwanger und meine Frau sagt
das geht nicht
liebe Kolleginnen und Union werden in
vier Jahren womöglich Jamaika vergessen
Sie ich komme zum Ende frau Präsidentin
wenn in vier Jahren womöglich Jamaika
singt vergessen sie sowieso wieder alle
guten Vorsätze und lassen sich von den
Grünen aus Lastenfahrrad setzen wer mit
seinem Automobil bleiben möchte wird
besser gleich die
automobilfahrerpartei die AFD danke
schön
[Applaus]
wir Bündnis 90 erteile ich das Wort der
Kollegin Susanne Menge und das ist in
ihrem in diesem Haus auch ihre Ärztinnen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrtes Präsidium sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren zu Kollege Schreiber möchte
ich sagen es ist keine Beliebigkeit
einer Regierung die Bedarfsplan
Überprüfung vorzunehmen sondern es ist
gesetzlich vorgeschrieben
sehr geehrte Abgeordnete die
Unionsfraktion feiert in ihrem Antrag
die vermeintlichen
planungsbeschleunigung der letzten
Wahlperiode aus unserer Sicht zu Unrecht
sie setzen auf Scheinlösung während die
wirksamen Maßnahmen 16 Jahren
kanzler:innenschaft gar nicht angepackt
wurden der Schwerpunkt der CSU-Minister
lag vor allem beim Straßenbau mit dem
Fokus auf Bayern die bestehende
Verkehrsinfrastruktur haben sie dagegen
völlig vernachlässigt marode und
unpassierbare Brücken sind ein Ergebnis
dieses politikversagens jetzt tun Sie so
als seien diese Missstände vor allem ein
Problem mangelnder
planungsbeschleunigung dabei waren es
ihre falschen verkehrspolitischen
Prioritäten von denen sie nun versuchen
abzulenken ein weiteres Beispiel die
Mittel für den Neubau im Schienennetz
waren unter csu-ministern auf ein
jämmerliches Niveau von etwas mehr als
eine Milliarde Euro jährlich abgesunken
das reichte auch im europäischen
Vergleich nur für einen hinteren Platz
besonders deutlich wird die
Vernachlässigung der Schiene bei den
Verbindungen zu unseren Nachbarländern
nicht einmal die Elektrifizierung von
Eisenbahnstrecken haben sie hinbekommen
seit 1998 versprechen wir zum Beispiel
Tschechien die Elektrifizierung der
Strecke Nürnberg Prag bis heute fahren
nur diese Loks auf dieser Strecke und
das soll bis 2028 so bleiben das ist ein
verkehrs- und klimapolitisches
Armutszeugnis beim Thema
Planungsverfahren gelten für uns vier
Anforderungen erstens der zügige
Verfahrensablauf zweitens die
rechtzeitige Beteiligung von Bürgerinnen
hohe Standards beim Natur- und
Umweltschutz und viertens absolute
Rechtssicherheit für die Vorhabenträger
legen wir diese Kriterien einmal an das
von ihnen auf den Weg gebrachte
maßnahmengesetz an ich greife die
Rechtssicherheit heraus und Frage wie
rechtssicher ist denn ein Gesetz dass
die EU-Kommission ein für die das
bürokommission ein
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren eingeleitet
hat das Gesetz beschneidet Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern sowie Umweltverbänden ihre
Möglichkeiten gegen Rechtsverstöße
vorgehen zu können das ist eine
Missachtung der ahuskonvention was die
EU-Kommission völlig zurecht moniert das
maßnahmengesetz in seiner bisherigen
Fassung bringt keine Beschleunigung
sondern maximale Rechtsunsicherheit sie
erweisen der planungsbeschleunigung
damit ein Bärendienst die Ursachen von
überlangen Planungsverfahren liegen oft
weniger bei den Verfahrensregeln sondern
vor allem am Personalmangel und früherer
Sparpolitik Personal fehlt auf allen
Ebenen der Planung und Genehmigung bei
den Planungsbüros in den entsprechenden
Abteilungen der Vorhabenträger bei den
anhörungs- und Genehmigungsbehörden und
schließlich auch bei den
Verwaltungsgerichten der Antrag der
Union bietet übrigens keine Lösung zum
problemfachpersonal an
werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
werden bei den kommenden
Haushaltsberatungen darauf achten dass
die Personalausstattung der
Genehmigungsbehörden mit der wachsenden
investitionslinie Schritt hält und
entsprechend aufgestockt wird die
Schiene ist ein Rückgrat der
Verkehrswende deshalb müssen wir vor
allem den Bau von schienenprojekten und
weiteren Vorhaben des öffentlichen
Verkehrs beschleunigen dem
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbarte
beschleunigungskommission Schiene muss
daher schnell aufgegleist werden dazu
gehört auch die Digitalisierung von
Planungs- und genehmigungsprozessen
Prozessen die sie im ampelvertrag
festgehalten wurde wie kann es im Jahr
2022 eigentlich sein dass wir die
Deutsche Bahn auf das digitale planen
mit building Information modeling
verpflichten dass die fertigen
Unterlagen dann aber in Papierform an
das Eisenbahn-Bundesamt weitergehen
lassen Sie mich abschließend noch etwas
zu Einordnung ihres Antrages sagen den
ich nur vor dem Hintergrund der
Landtagswahlen erklären kann sie wollen
die Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen bei
der Planung von Verkehrsinfrastrukturen
begrenzen und das Naturschutzrecht
beschneiden und dieses alte denken
leitet ihren gesamten Antrag Natur und
Umweltschutz sind eigentlich Ballast
Klimaschutz und Artenschutz sind aber
zwei Seiten einer Medaille und wir
bündnisgrüne lassen es nicht zu denn
kurz vor Landtagswahlen versucht werden
soll das eine gegen das andere
auszuspielen
Sorgfalt kommt vor Schnelligkeit heißt
es in einer Redewendung angesichts der
Herausforderungen der Klimakrise müssen
wir beides unter einen Hut bekommen ich
danke für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
auch seine erste Rede hält uns jetzt der
Kollege Henning Rehbaum für die Fraktion
der CDU CSU
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Sperrung der Rahmen der Talbrücke ist
ein Weckruf für so manchen hier im Haus
wie viele Jahre mussten wir uns als
Union anhören dass man kein Geld mehr in
Autobahn stecken sollte
dieselben Kräfte die uns als Union für
zu viel Geld für die Straßen kritisiert
haben stellen sich jetzt hin und werfen
uns vor wir hätten zu wenig investiert
das ist absurd
ich habe selber 2017 die
koalitionsverhandlung für den Verkehr in
Nordrhein-Westfalen mitgeführt Kollege
Berkan Kollegin Slavik nach 16 40 Jahren
SPD geführter Landesregierung mit einer
ganz kleinen Unterbrechung und wir haben
in die Schubladen geguckt des
Ministeriums und da haben wir keine
Baureife brückenplanung gefunden
wenn Sie dieses Fass aufmachen können
sie nur verlieren
Rot-Grün wollte überhaupt gar keinen
Straßenbau sie haben Gelder nach Berlin
zurückgeben müssen weil nichts fertig
geplant war selbst Verkehrsminister
groschek SPD hat sich beschwert über
eine durchgrünte Verkehrspolitik bei der
nichts fertig wird
die CDU geführte und gemeinsam mit der
FDP gut organisierte Landesregierung
nimmt mittlerweile Gelder aus dem Bund
die andere Bundesländer zurückgeben und
wir haben heute ein rekordhaushalt in
Nordrhein-Westfalen für Schienenwege für
den Straßenbau für Reaktivierung von
Schienenstrecken für den ÖPNV für
Fahrrad sie reden wir machen
unter der Union ist der Verkehrsetat für
Straße Schiene Fahrrad Wasserstraße des
Bundes nahezu verdoppelt worden dazu
vier planungsbeschleunigungsgesetze die
jetzt konsequent umzusetzen sind beim
Infrastrukturbau haben wir kein
Erkenntnisproblem meine Damen und Herren
nein wir haben ein krasses
Umsetzungsproblem das gilt für Straße
Schiene oder Radwege genauso wie für
Windkraft Solarparks Pipelines oder
wasserstoffprojekte jeder weiß das
Problem sind die schier endlosen
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren 30
Jahre für eine Bahnstrecke zehn Jahre
für ein Windrad 8 Jahre für einen
Radschnellweg fünf Jahre für den
Ersatzbau einer Autobahnbrücke wir
brauchen massive Beschleunigung weit
über die vier guten gesetzespakete der
großen Koalition hinaus
wichtig ist auch den Artenschutz zu
modernisieren und das wohlgemerkt nicht
nur bei Straßenbauprojekten hunderte
Windräder in ganz Deutschland können
seit Jahren nicht gebaut werden weil
etwa der Rote Milan oder der Uhu in der
Nachbarschaft gesichtet wurde der
nrw-landesverband erneuerbare Energien
sah sich letztes Jahr wegen überbordener
artenschutzklagen gezwungen vor der
Zentrale des NABU in Düsseldorf zu
demonstrieren so weit musste es erstmal
kommen und eine jahrelange Hängepartie
für die Menschen in Lüdenscheid wegen
ein paar Fledermäusen im abgängigen
Brückenkörper das kann man außerhalb der
Parlamente Behörden und NGOs niemandem
erklären
wir müssen Artenschutz Planungsrecht und
Klimaschutz miteinander versöhnen die
Verfahren müssen schneller werden und
das muss man wollen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Ampel man muss alte
Glaubenssätze über Bord werfen und zwar
konsequent
letzter Punkt warum braucht man
eigentlich jahrelange
Planfeststellungsverfahren für
Ersatzneubauten von Brücken die an
derselben Stelle entstehen denn auf der
A45 wie bei hunderten weiteren Bahnen
und Autobahnbrücken ändert sich faktisch
nichts da steht heute eine Brücke und da
wird auch in Zukunft eine Brücke stehen
da gibt es nur eins Bagger bestellen
statt Fledermäuse zählen
die vier beschleunigungspakete der groko
müssen umgesetzt werden heute packt die
Union noch eins oben drauf zur
Abstimmung für Klimaschutz und
alltagstaugliche Mobilität herzlichen
Dank
[Applaus]
und eine folgt nach der anderen wir
haben den Wettbewerb der ersten reden
wir freuen uns drauf und zwar spricht
für die FDP-Fraktion jetzt der Kollege
Jürgen lenders
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir werden bei all dem was wir tun stets
die Technologie Offenheit im Auge
behalten und wir werden dabei an die
Menschen denken die Menschen in den
urbanen Gebieten in den ländlichen
Räumen und da scheuen wir uns nicht auch
alle Verkehrsträger mitzudenken da
gehört das Fahrrad dazu da gehört der
das Auto dazu mit seinem
Verbrennungsmotor da gehört die Schiene
dazu meine Damen und Herren wenn jetzt
hier die Kollegen und Kollegen von der
Union die Frage nach den e-fuels
aufmachen kann ich nur sagen wir müssen
darum uns kümmern dass wir möglichst die
möglichst die Produktion von efuels
hochfahren und meine Damen und Herren
dann würde sich so manche Kritik von
ihnen auch erledigen
meine Damen und Herren was
Infrastruktur bedeuten kann für Menschen
gerade nehmen wir mal das Beispiel
Lüdenscheid wo Pendler wo Anwohner wo
Unternehmer davon betroffen sind dass
sie jetzt von durchgangsverkehren
belastet sind meine Damen und Herren das
ist nahezu eine Katastrophe für die
Menschen vor Ort nehmen wir mal die
salzbachtalbrücke in Wiesbaden da war
das nicht nur die Autobahn da war das
auch die gleich die
Schieneninfrastruktur die auch damit
erlegen ist eine Landeshauptstadt war
über Monate abgeschnitten sozusagen von
dem pendlerstrom meine Damen und Herren
das können wir und es werden wir so
nicht akzeptieren
aber jetzt mal zu ihrem Antrag
geschätzte Union das sind 33 Punkte die
sie hier aufgeschrieben haben das sind
ein eigentlich 33 Punkte eine Aufzählung
ihrer eigenen unzulässlichkeit weil sie
haben doch in den letzten Jahren regiert
meine Damen und
es steht ja auch nicht alles nur
falsches drin da sind ja durchaus auch
Punkte dabei die haben wir auch selber
schon gefordert das ist da gibt es auch
Punkte da kann man auch drüber
diskutieren aber Herr Kollege Schreiner
eins möchte ich Ihnen dann schon auch
noch mal sagen dass wir die
Bedarfsprüfung die auf einem gesetzfuß
was sie selber gemacht haben jetzt
ignorieren sollen also wir sollen jetzt
einen Gesetz was sie selber auf den Weg
gebracht haben ignorieren meine Damen
und das kannst ja wohl wirklich nicht
sein
und so mancher Punkt ist durchaus zu
diskutieren der Rehbaum hat ja auch
gerade schon auf dem Punkt 2 zuletzt
reflektiert aus ihrem Antrag meine Damen
und Herren es gibt ja durchaus auch in
unseren Reihen
Personen die darüber nachdenken was die
Frage was ist noch verhältnismäßig und
wie inwieweit ist die
die Frage der
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung eine
Hemmung aber Herr Kollege das
Hauptproblem ist hier dass der nationale
Gesetzgeber den Verzicht auf
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen nicht
alleine entscheiden kann hier ist es
zwingend notwendig dass Europa
europäische rechtsverändert so einfach
wie sie sich das machen geht es nun mal
nicht
und Herr Kollege was sie einfach sich
auch den Vorwurf gefallen lassen müssen
wenn man ihren Antrag liest hat man
nicht den Eindruck dass sie über die
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung mal
nachdenken wollen sondern dass Sie sie
einfach komplett Schleifen wollen und
das machen wir nicht mit
meine Damen und
viele ihrer Punkte sind reine
Symbolpolitik nehmen wir mal die
Forderung des Vergaberecht zu
überarbeiten das klingt ja ganz schön
aber alleine in dem Bereich wo die
Länder dafür zuständig sind er meine
lieben Kollegen und Kollegen da haben
wir überhaupt gar keine
Gesetzgebungskompetenz und wenn sie
solche Anträge hier vorlegen sollten Sie
zur Ehrlichkeit aussagen dass wir das
überhaupt hier von hier nicht regeln
können meine Damen und Herren
absurd
absurd ist die Forderung Artikel 2
EU-Vergaberichtlinien meine Damen und
Herren auch wenn Sie in den letzten 16
Jahren
regiert haben den Verfall der
Infrastruktur kann man sicherlich nicht
dann mit Dringlichkeit begründen das
Problem ist längst vorher schon bekannt
gewesen meine Damen und Herren und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass die dann
auch noch eine Direktvergabe fordern in
Millionenhöhe da kann ich sie nur vor
warnen solch einen Weg zu beschreiten
das öffnet der Korruption Tür und Tor
meine Damen und Herren wir als Koalition
wären einen anderen Weg gehen vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
und allen die hier das erste mal reden
sei noch mal eingeschrieben die anderen
Male sind wir nicht so frei und
großzügig
als nächstes hat für die
SPD-Fraktion kW masuri das Wort
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ich muss sagen fünf Seiten zum Thema
planungsbeschleunigung unterzeichnet von
Alexander Dobrindt haben mich dann im
Ergebnis noch ein bisschen mehr
erheitert als ihre aktuelle Stunde zum
Klimaschutz
und natürlich fragt man sich bei
interessierter Lektüre warum haben sie
das denn nicht in ihrer Regierungszeit
gemacht ich kann es ihnen sagen weil die
größten Bremsen für die mobilitäts- und
Energiewende in diesem Land in den
letzten 16 Jahren nicht Rotmilan
Einwendung und Verwaltungsprozess hießen
sondern Dobrindt Altmaier und scheuer
meine Damen und Herren
und die
Defizite in Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren wollen sie jetzt
im Fingerstreich auf fünf Seiten lösen
vor allem beim Aktionismus da macht die
Union auf der Oppositionsbank jetzt so
richtig Tempo nur sind das eben keine
seriösen Vorschläge Einstein sagt alles
muss so einfach wie möglich sein aber
eben nicht einfacher und ich will einige
Herausforderungen unter dem Stichwort
planungsbeschleunigung nennen erstens
weniger Papier und digitale
behördenabstimmung zweitens da wo es
sinnvoll ist sollten unterschiedliche
Verwaltungseinheiten parallel zueinander
planen und nicht nacheinander drittens
es braucht Vertrauen und Akzeptanz und
behördliche Entscheidung dafür muss die
Öffentlichkeit möglichst früh einbezogen
werden viertens und das ist eine
schwierige Baustelle wir müssen den
Prüfungsaufwand für Behörden und
Gerichte reduzieren die Begründung eines
Bebauungsplans bei mir in meiner Stadt
Frankfurt hat etwa 100 Seiten für die
Genehmigung einer Windenergieanlage
können Sie einen kleinen
Besprechungsraum mit leitzordn erfüllen
und für ein großes
Planfeststellungsverfahren reicht das
wahrscheinlich gar nicht aus
im Artenschutzrecht müssen wir
Prüfungsschritte standardisieren man
muss nicht in jedem Verfahren bei Adam
und Eva anfangen weil es um den Schutz
von Populationen und nicht von
Individuen geht
wir wollen den Planungsprozess straffen
so weit möglich müssen Einwendungen die
bis zu einem bestimmten Stichtag nicht
erhoben sind für das weitere Verfahren
ausgeschlossen sein im Fachjargon nennt
man das Präklusion und sechstens wir
wollen die Verwaltungsgerichtsbarkeit in
die Lage versetzen schneller zu einem
verfahrensende zu kommen meine früheren
verwaltungsrechtsprofessoren Reimer und
eifert würden sich jetzt sicher freuen
wenn ich das alles vertiefe dafür reicht
unsere Zeit heute aber nicht aus denn
wir reden hier meine Damen und Herren
über nichts Geringeres als die größte
Verwaltungsmodernisierung seit Gründung
der Bundesrepublik und das wollen sie
jetzt einfach mal auf fünf Seiten lösen
sie hatten 16 Jahre Zeit dafür meine
Damen und Herren
und in diesen 16 Jahren haben sie den
verwaltungsgrundsatz der
Wirtschaftlichkeit und Sparsamkeit vor
allem dann hoch gehalten wenn es nicht
um in ihre Ministerbüros ging aber die
großen Planfeststellungsverfahren meine
Damen und Herren die bearbeiten sich
eben nicht von selbst sondern Menschen
bearbeiten die und deswegen ist das
Thema Personalmangel auch eines dass wir
jetzt auf die Agenda packen werden wir
meine Damen und Herren werden diese
Dinge jetzt ressortübergreifend angehen
weil es gerade in diesen Tagen auch
darum geht zu zeigen dass demokratische
Rechtsstaaten etwas bewegen können und
wir setzen auch auf einen Bundeskanzler
der sich für diese Themen im Europarecht
stark macht die ersten ampelgesetze
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen werden
wir hier in Kürze diskutieren und ich
bin gespannt was die CSU in Bayern bis
dahin beschleunigt hat wo Unternehmen
abwandern weil planungsbeschleunigung
bei ihnen nämlich vor allem aus einem
Stoff besteht nämlich heißer Luft ich
danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
im Reigen der ersten Rede begrüße ich
jetzt und wir freuen uns drauf Martina
Engelhardt Kopf für die cdu/cs
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sicher
erreichen auch Sie in diesem Tagen aber
seit Wochen und Monate die Hilferufe von
Bürgerinnen und Bürger aber auch vom
Betrieben doch endlich etwas gegen die
exportierenden Spritpreise an den
Tankstellen zu Unternehmen auf die
bisher ungenügende Reaktion der
Bundesregierung will ich an dieser
Stelle gar nicht erst eingehen es ist
längst überfällig zu handeln besser
heute als morgen schnell und
unbürokratisch und dieser Hilferuf zeigt
doch eins was für die Zukunft der
Mobilität der Verkehrspolitik
entscheidend ist Mobilität muss für alle
bezahlbar bleiben
und erlauben Sie mir an dieser Stelle
einen kurzen Einwurf
feministische Debatten wer jetzt wie
entlastet wird ob Männer oder Frauen
mehr Autofahren und entsprechend was
zurückbekommen müssen das ist doch Haare
sträuben das ist ein Schlag ins Gesicht
für betroffene Unternehmer aber auch für
Familien für Bürgerinnen und Bürger
insbesondere in den ländlichen
Wahlkreisen es ist völlig absurd an
dieser Stelle völlig Fülle fehl am Platz
und damit dieses Ziel erreicht werden
kann fordern wir heute in unserem Antrag
die Bundesregierung auf bei der
Umsetzung der Klimaschutzziele
technologieoffen aber auch Ideologie
frei zu handeln und wenn wir die
Debatten in der letzten halben Stunde
betrachten steckt so viel Ideologie in
der Argumentation vieler Redner und das
bringt uns für die Zukunft nicht weiter
wenn wir das Ziel erreichen wollen
Mobilität für alle aber auch bezahlbare
Mobilität klimafreundlich in der Stadt
und auf dem Land ich komme aus einem
ländlichen Wahlkreis Schwandorf Cham
Wörth an der Donau und Bramberg lade Sie
sehr gerne ein sich dort auch die
Mobilität vor Ort anzusehen die Zukunft
der Ausbau ÖPNV aber wir brauchen auch
das Auto wir sind darauf angewiesen und
dafür treten wir auch ein
und natürlich kann das Auto
elektrisch betrieben werden und die
Ausbauziele im Koalitionsvertrag
geregelt sind sehr ambitioniert aber es
ist nicht richtig nur auf eine
Technologie auf eine Karte zu setzen
sondern wir brauchen entsprechend hier
auch Alternativen ja wir müssen alle
Möglichkeiten alle Instrumente in
Betracht ziehen um uns hier breit für
die Zukunft aufzustellen ich denke an
alternative Kraftstoffe wie sie auch
bereits genannt wurden an e-fuels an
Biokraftstoffe aber auch an Wasserstoff
um hier entsprechend auch Beiträge für
eine klimafreundliche Transformation des
Verkehrs zu leisten
und selbst wenn die hochgesteckten Ziele
in Sachen E-Mobilität 15 Millionen Autos
vollelektrisch betrieben bis 2030
erreicht werden können dann werden doch
zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch viele
Verbrennungsmotoren auf unseren
deutschen Autobahnen fahren und
entsprechend auch hier brauchen wir
Ansätze um die bestandsflotte die er zu
diesem Zeitpunkt noch eine lange
Lebensdauer vor sich hat auch
Alternativen anzubieten und diese
bestandsflotte klimaneutraler auch
entsprechend zu betreiben
gerade für den ländlichen Raum wäre ein
Markt Hochlauf alternativer Kraftstoffe
eine große Chance nicht nur weil wir
dort in der Zukunft egal wie angetrieben
auch die motorisierten Individualverkehr
brauchen sondern weil wir auch
Biokraftstoffe in der Landwirtschaft
produzieren können ich denke hier an
Abfallprodukte im Sinne der
Wiederverwertung Biogasanlagen
Aufbereitung entsprechende
Energieerzeugung das erzeugt auch
Wertschöpfung in der Fläche bietet
Alternativen aber hierfür fehlen uns
leider die rechtlichen Rahmen keine
Planungssicherheit für Investoren genau
an diesen Stellen müssen wir jetzt die
Weichen stellen um auch hier uns breiter
aufzustellen das gleiche auch was die
diffuse anbelangt weitere Möglichkeit um
hier auch klimafreundlichen Kraftstoff
zu produzieren aber das ist gegenwärtig
nicht durchsetzbar weil eben auf
politischer Ebene die entsprechenden
Rahmenbedingungen wählen und hier
fordern wir die Bundesregierung auf auch
in der EU völlig Ideologie frei aber
auch
technologieoffen dafür einzutreten dass
eben auch e-fuels bei der Anrechnung der
flottengrenzwerte Berücksichtigung
finden für die Zukunft der Mobilität
[Applaus]
manchmal habe ich so ein räuspern und
das heißt dass sie doch die Redezeit
jetzt sehr weit ausgedehnt haben
die Bundesregierung muss deshalb jetzt
die Weichen stellen um entsprechend auch
hier technologieoffen die Mobilität der
Zukunft zu ermöglichen setzen wir heute
mit unserem Antrag ein starkes Zeichen
mit einer Mix aus verschiedenen
antriebsenergien der viele Chancen
bietet aber insbesondere eine bezahlbare
Mobilität für alle in der Fläche
ermöglicht vielen Dank
vielen Dank
auf ihre wahrscheinlich beim nächsten
Mal wird sie sich mir anstrengen aber
jetzt kommt hier schon direkt der
nächste Kollege mit einer ersten Rede
und das ist Christian schreibeder für
die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen es ist doch so
keine Klimawende ohne eine Verkehrswende
keine Verkehrswende ohne eine bessere
Bahn und keine bessere Bahn ohne eine
bessere Infrastruktur
und wenn wir sie wirklich weg haben
wollen diese fatale Abhängigkeit von Öl
und Gas von Russland und Co dann
brauchen wir neue Antriebe dann brauchen
wir eine neue Mobilität wir wollen
deshalb einen Aufbruch in der
mobilitätspolitik und wir wollen eine
Verkehrspolitik für die vielen das heißt
auch kein verkehrsmittelverteufeln auch
nicht das Auto aber wenn wir unsere
CO2-Ziele schaffen und mehr Freiheit
wollen dann muss der Umstieg auf die
Bahn endlich leichter werden
und leichter wird er nur wenn die Bahn
endlich ein starkes Rückgrat bekommt und
das kann nur das Schienennetz sein
dieses Netz wollen wir ausbauen denn
darauf wollen wir den deutschlandtakt
fahren alle halbe Stunde in jede
Richtung clever verknüpft für mehr
Fahrgäste und mehr Güter auf der Bahn in
kaum etwas wurde in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik so wenig investiert wie
in das Schienennetz wir fahren meistens
von den gleichen alten Bahnhöfen auf die
gleichen alten Strecken hier setzen wir
an den für uns gilt schnelle
Schienenwege sind das Herzstück sind
unser Herzstück der mobilitätswende sie
sind das Rückgrat des Masterplans
Schienenverkehr um die Fahrgastzahlen zu
verdoppeln doch dafür müssen wir auch
einiges halbieren vor allem die
Planungs- und die Bauzeiten
in vielen Feldern gilt der Satz ganz
sicher nicht aber in Sachen bauen und
Verkehr sage ich hindurch aus bewusst
wir müssen mehr Schweiz Wagen
mangelhafte Bürgerbeteiligung hat den
Eidgenossen noch niemand unterstellt und
trotzdem realisieren sie selbst komplexe
Projekte wie den Gotthardtunnel deutlich
schneller als wir Neubaustrecken übers
flache Land aber wenn wir wirklich
wollen dann können wir das auch
inklusive einer frühen guten und vor
allem gezielten Bürgerbeteiligung
neben der Halbierung der Bauzeiten
brauchen wir aber auch ein ganzes Bündel
kurzfristiger Maßnahmen und genau dafür
bilden wir die beschleunigungskommission
Schiene wir stellen große weichen wie
das digitale Netzmanagement damit mehr
Züge ins bestehende Netz passen und wir
stellen vermeintlich kleine weichen mit
allerdings weitreichender Wirkung mit
den Bau von verbindungskurven damit kein
Zug mehr umständlich umdrehen muss oder
den Bau von überholgleisen damit unsere
Züge nicht hintereinander Schlange
stehen denn diese berühmt berüchtigten
Verzögerungen im Betriebsablauf die
müssen doch endlich der Vergangenheit
angehören
unterm Strich wollen wir vor allem mehr
Flexibilität für mehr Kapazität und dazu
bauen wir auch die Deutsche Bahn um aus
DB-Netz und db-station und Service
bilden wir eine neue schlagkräftige
infrastruktursparte und zwar strikt
gemeinwohlorientiert mit der strikten
Auflage Gewinne aus dem Betrieb des
Netzes müssen auch genau dort wieder
investiert werden doch zu einem besseren
Netz gehört noch mehr eine stärkere
Elektrifizierung bis hin zu 75%
Abdeckung bis 2030 oder die
Schienenanbindung neuer Gewerbegebiete
die endlich wieder Standard werden muss
und noch etwas ist uns wichtig wo es um
die Wirtschaftlichkeit neuer Strecken
geht muss der klimaschutzfaktor deutlich
mehr zählen die Menschen zum Beispiel
bei mir im Wahlkreis in Darmstadt in
Mutterstadt in der Gartenstadt oder in
Neuhofen die warten 10 ist auf ihre
neuen Stadtbahn und währenddessen prüft
die öffentliche Hand die
Wirtschaftlichkeit und prüft und prüft
und prüft dabei ist uns doch allen klar
nichts macht den Verkehr und unsere
Freiheit in Energiefragen so
zukunftsfest wie neue Antriebe und
schnelle Schienenwege und dafür nehmen
wir
und dafür nehmen wir jetzt Fahrt auf
denn nach 12 Jahren Verkehrsministerin
von der CSU gibt es viel zu tun packen
wir es an vielen Dank
für diese Debatte ist es jetzt die
letzte der ersten reden und sie kommt
von 20 Michaelsen von verbündnis 90
Sekunden
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit
ihren Anträgen zeigt die Union einmal
mehr warum wir da stehen wo wir stehen
mit der Union gibt es keine
Verkehrswende denn mit ihrer verfehlten
Energie-
jetzt stellen sie nachdem sie zwölf
Jahre lang das Verkehrsministerium
geführt haben einen Antrag zur
Transformation der Automobilindustrie
und ja diese Transformation ist bitter
nötig just Anfang dieser Woche hat das
Umweltbundesamt festgestellt dass das
Klimaziel im verkehrssektoren 2021
deutlich verfehlt wurde das
Klimaschutzgesetz verpflichtet uns schon
jetzt die Emissionen im Verkehrssektor
auf 85 Millionen Tonnen in 2030 zu
reduzieren das ist eine riesige
Herausforderung insbesondere für den
PKW-Bereich aus dem 60% der Emissionen
im Verkehr stammen
weil die Transformation der
Automobilindustrie nun zwölf Jahre lang
gebremst und verschleppt wurde müssen
wir umso zielgerichteter die richtigen
Instrumente einsetzen wir haben nun
keine Zeit mehr für unionswünsche aller
flugtaxis oder Wasserstoffautos für alle
die Ergebnisse der Wissenschaft sind
nämlich eindeutig das hat im letzten
Jahr der vom Bund geförderte areat eine
Report noch einmal sehr deutlich gezeigt
im Verkehrssektor sind die Klimaziele
2030 überhaupt nur dann zu erreichen
wenn wir im PKW-Bereich massiv auf
vollelektrische Antriebe setzen die
Automobilindustrie hat verstanden dass
es ohne Klimaneutralität nicht mehr geht
und das Festhalten am Verbrenner ist nur
noch eine Außenseiterposition die
anderen Kraftstoffe brauchen wir
ebenfalls dringend aber doch nicht für
Privat PKW sondern überall da wo wir mit
Elektro nicht weiterkommen das hat die
Automobilindustrie im Gegensatz zu ihnen
längst erkannt
den Rahmen für die nächsten Jahre haben
wir im Koalitionsvertrag eindeutig
definiert wir wollen auf den 1,5
grad-pfad kommen so wie wir es bereits
2015 mit dem Pariser Klimaschutzabkommen
unterschrieben haben
wir wissen aber auch mit der
antriebswende allein werden wir die
Klimaschutzziele im Verkehr nicht
erreichen
deshalb ist es so dringend dass wir
jetzt die Weichen neu stellen dass wir
jetzt investieren in nachhaltiger
Alternativen dabei darf eben nicht
länger nur das Auto im Mittelpunkt
stehen so wie es bei der Union der Fall
war sondern die Mobilität für Menschen
deshalb werden wir die Alternativen zum
Auto ausbauen wir werden investieren in
eine in die Bahn und in einen besseren
ÖPNV der die Menschen da abholt und
hinbringt wo Sie es brauchen
wir werden investieren in die
Infrastruktur für Rat und Fußverkehr
denn wenn es nur eine Bundesstraße und
keinen Radweg gibt fahren die Menschen
nicht mit dem Rad ins nächste Dorf und
wenn das Dorf keinen Fußweg hat ist
selbst die Nachbarin nur schwer zu Fuß
erreichbar zu oft aber werden die
Kommunen zu oft aber werden die Kommunen
von den Bundesgesetzen ausgebremst wenn
sie ihre öffentlichen Räume neu
gestalten wollen
deshalb werden wir und das sieht der
Koalitionsvertrag ausdrücklich vor das
Straßenverkehrsgesetz reformieren
wir werden Klima und Umweltschutz
Gesundheit und städtebauliche
Entwicklung als neue Ziele im
Straßenverkehrsgesetz verankern und wir
werden damit den Kommunen mehr Freiheit
einräumen für die Gestaltung vor Ort
damit wir endlich nicht mehr nur Verkehr
produzieren sondern alle Menschen mobil
machen was für ein Glück für die
Menschen und die Mobilität in diesem
Land dass diese Anträge von einer
Oppositionsfraktion stammen wir werden
sie ablehnen vielen Dank
es hat Matthias Stein das Wort für die
SPD-Fraktion
ja genau das
wird aber nicht freundlich Herr Kollege
Schreiner sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger über die letzten
vier Jahre habe ich als zuständiger
Berichterstatter in dem Bereich schnelle
Planung und Genehmigung von
Verkehrsprojekten für meine Fraktion
gearbeitet wir haben mit der Union vier
Gesetze verabschiedet wir haben diverse
Vorschläge mit ihnen diskutiert und auch
für Beschleunigung gesorgt aber mit dem
Blick auf ihren Antrag jetzt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
scheint es mir zu sein dass sie da
einiges vergessen haben
denn sie fordern Dinge die bereits
umgesetzt sind
sie verlangen Maßnahmen die wir zwar
diskutiert aber aus gutem Grund
verworfen haben sie machen Vorschläge
die wenn man sie zu Ende denkt nicht
rechtssicher umgesetzt werden können
und vor allem scheinen sie unseren
Wunschzettel abgeschrieben zu haben Best
Practice Beispiele Leitfäden für
Verwaltung eine Kompetenzstelle
Bürgerbeteiligung kräftig mehr Personal
und finanzielle Ausstattung für Behörden
einheitliche kompensationsregelung für
Betroffene all dies sind sinnvolle
Maßnahmen
aber ich hätte erwartet dass sie den den
letzten vier Jahren haben sie genau
diese Maßnahmen immer wieder blockiert
mit ihrem Ministerium und mit andreas
Scheuer an der Spitze und wir brauchen
weder ihre Tipps noch ihre anträgewerte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
Sozialdemokraten packen gemeinsam mit
den ampelparteien in dieser Regierung
das Thema planungsbeschleunigung an
und wir
und wir tun das mit Respekt vor all
denjenigen die planen die bauen die
überwachen die genehmigen und was die
Union immer noch nicht verstanden hat
diesen Menschen müssen wir den Rücken
stärken
wir müssen ein Umfeld schaffen in dem
vorhandenes Wissen genutzt wird in dem
Ermessensspielräume bestmöglich genutzt
werden hier hilft kein Dschungel an
rechtlichen Regelungen wir brauchen
pragmatische Lösungsansätze
praxistaugliche Maßnahmen und vor allen
Dingen Empathie für Betroffene die dann
unter Lärmschutz neiden denn das ist
nicht nur naturschutzfragen die wir hier
haben sondern es geht auch um Lärmschutz
vor allen Dingen und nicht durch laute
anreden und schlechte Anträge können wie
eine nachhaltige Beschleunigung
Erreichen von Planungs- und
beschleunigungsprozessen sondern nur
durch ein beherztes anpacken und wir
werden das mit einer
sozialdemokratischen Bundesregierung tun
vielen Dank
vielen Dank ich beende die Aussprache
und wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den
Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu auf
Drucksache 10.09 mit dem Titel durch
technologieoffenheit die Transformation
der Automobilindustrie beschleunigen und
die Klimaziele erreichen wer stimmt für
den Antrag
wer stimmt dagegen
Enthaltungen
es gibt keine Enthaltungen dafür hat
bestimmt die einbringende Fraktion der
cdu/csu dagegen alle anderen Fraktionen
damit ist der Antrag abgelehnt
Tagesordnungspunkt 22b Abstimmung über
den Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu auf
Drucksache 10 11 mit dem Titel Tempo
machen bei Verkehrsprojekten weitere
beschleunigungspotenziale heben wer
stimmt dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
Enthaltungen
der Antrag ist abgelehnt bei Zustimmung
durch die cdu/csu und die AFD die
übrigen Fraktion des Hauses haben
dagegen gestimmt ich komme jetzt
ich komme zurück
zu Tagesordnungspunkt
21a wir kommen zur Abstimmung über die
Entschließungsanträge
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
AFD auf Drucksache 10
85 ich überlege gerade ob ich es
andersrum machen muss
muss erst wieder abnehmen muss ich nicht
ne muss erst die namentliche bekannt
geben ja erst entschuldigen jetzt habe
ich mir gedacht verzeihung das ist hier
falsch einsortiert also ich gebe Ihnen
die Abstimmungsergebnisse der
namentlichen Abstimmung bekannt über den
Entwurf eines Gesetzes zur Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes und anderer
Vorschriften auf den Drucksachen 20
958 20 10 70 und 20 1094
hier handelt es sich um einen
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP
abgegebene Stimmkarten waren 667 mit ja
haben bestimmt 388 mit 977 es gab zwei
Enthaltungen
damit ist das Gesetz angenommen und wir
kommen zur Abstimmung über die
Entschließungsanträge der
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
AFD auf Drucksache 1085 wer stimmt für
den Entschließungsantrag
die Gegenstimmen
die Enthaltungen
damit ist der Antrag abgelehnt
zugestimmt hat die einbringende Fraktion
alle anderen haben abgelehnt
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion Die
Linke auf Drucksache 1086 wer stimmt
dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
Enthaltungen damit ist der Antrag
ebenfalls abgelehnt die einbringende
Fraktion DIE LINKE hat zugestimmt alle
anderen haben abgelehnt
jetzt rufe ich auf den
Tagesordnungspunkt 23 Beratung der
Beschlussempfehlung des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses zu dem Antrag der
Bundesregierung zur Fortsetzung der
Beteiligung bewaffneter deutscher
Streitkräfte an der Mission der
Vereinten Nationen in der Republik
Südsudan unmiss über die Entschluss im
Beschlussempfehlungen werden wir später
namentlich abstimmen
39 Minuten sind für die Aussprache
vorgesehen